Polgars.
Paul Guys
Moin, guck mal der Eax ist auch am Start.
Dazu kann ich eigentlich nur sagen, so habe ich die richtige Kategorie eingestellt.
Ja, wir sind Science and Technology heute und wir haben natürlich wieder keine Qualitätsoption.
Lull.
Immer der gleiche Struggle ey, jedes Mal, jedes Mal, wenn ich live gehe, keine Qualitätsoption.
Das ist so random, gefühlt 20% der Fälle keine, äh, ungefähr 20% der Fälle habe ich
heute.
Wollen wir mal kurz meine Stream Vorschau neu laden.
Easy.
Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen, sind alle irgendwie Red Dead Redemption Spielen und nur
ich wieder nicht.
Ich bin wahrscheinlich der einzige, der sich das nicht gekauft hat.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, was das überhaupt für, äh, was das überhaupt für Kritiken
hat.
Wahrscheinlich übertrieben gut.
Ich habe gesehen, bei der Game Star hat es irgendwie 690 Punkte gekriegt, das ist echt
extrem viel.
Ob man da jetzt was drauf gibt oder nicht, muss man sich selbst überlegen, aber anteilmäßig
ist das halt wirklich viel.
Was macht Max, wir programmieren heute das Memetool weiter und ich, ich habe ja schon
auf Stream weiter gebastelt, also es ist jetzt langsam, langsam, aber sicher wird es Feintuning
angesagt, weil der Großteil der Sache funktioniert.
Ja, Red Dead 97, das ist halt echt viel, ne?
Das ist wirklich saumäßig viel, warum geht denn die Seite ein, achso, weil ich den komischen
Pop-Up wieder annehmen muss.
Heftig, 97 ist echt sehr viel, haben die eigentlich eine besten Liste, ja, uiuiui,
okay, all-time, all-time, im Prinzip, was, Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 2, 98 und damit hätte
ich jetzt nicht gerechnet.
Im Endeffekt teilen sich so die ersten 10 Plätze zu einer Mischung aus Nintendo Spielen
und aus Rockstar Games Spielen, wie lange streamst du schon, keine Ahnung, 5 Minuten
habe ich angemacht, nicht lange.
Ja, ich weiß, halt 96, das ist extrem viel, aber es sind immer so Top 20 zum größten
Teil Nintendo Spiele.
Ah, okay, man kann so, okay, dann noch mal PC, PC of all time, Half-Life 2, ja gut, Valve
hat ja keinen Bock mehr, Games zu machen, die verdienen ja mit Steam genug, easy, was
ist mit der Musik los, was anderes machen, wupp wupp wupp, ich mach das nicht, wenn irgendwie
komische Stimmen im Hintergrund sind bei der Musik, das lenkt immer ab, ah, so müsste
die Lautstärke eigentlich passen, easy, Game ist mega, bin schon in Kapitel 2, wenn der
Multiplayer rauskommt, bin ich gespannt, okay, ach, es soll ein Multiplayer kommen, hab ich
gar nichts von gelesen, aber ehrlich gesagt, ich bin halt kein Open World Fan, deswegen
ich, ich bin wahrscheinlich der einzige, der sich Red Dead Redemption nicht gekauft hat
und wahrscheinlich auch nicht kaufen wird, ich hab zwar GTA 2, äh, 2, ja GTA 2 hab ich
auch, äh, GTA 5 auf PC, aber ich hab, wir können mal gucken, wie viele Spielstunden
ich habe, ah nee, da muss ich mich mal, ich muss mal kurz den Bildschirm schwarz machen,
wenn ich mich bei Steam einlogge, dass hier nichts geleakt wird, das wollen wir ja nicht,
nee, wird gar nichts mehr geleakt, haben sie Optimized bei Steam, wie es aussieht, so,
also bei GTA, wenn man hier mal guckt, hab ich ganze, ach, gibt's das nicht bei Steam,
Moment, nee, alles heißt nicht geht, das ist Grand, 100, also 2 Stunden, das ist nichts,
ja, das ist absolut nichts, aber daran sieht man halt, ich bin einfach kein Open World
Typ, ja, ist einfach nichts für mich, kann man, kann man Steam nach gespielter Zeit sortieren?
Hm, wisst ihr, ob man, ob man, ob man Games auf Steam nach Zeit sortieren kann, wo man
am meisten gespielt hat? Geht das? Nee, ich weiß, nee, aufs Profil kann ich jetzt nicht
gehen, weil ich keine Ahnung hab, was in dem Profil alles drinsteht, weiß nicht, ich will
das mal sehen, aber es ist natürlich, wäre schön, wenn man das in der Library sortieren
könnte, wat, warum hab ich da von die VR-Version, ich hab keine VR-Version gekauft, oder war
die dabei, ach, keine Ahnung, tja, gut, ähm, wir basteln heute ein bisschen weiter, soll
ich euch mal die aktuelle Version zeigen, ja, also, easy, wir schmeißen, wir schmeißen
den Kram mal weg, wir schmeißen den Kram mal weg und dann zeige ich euch, was man alles
machen kann mittlerweile, also das ist deutlich ordentlicher als die erste Version und auch
viel einfacher zu erweitern und da, da wär ich bestimmt glücklicher mit sein, da in Zukunft
weiter dran zu basteln als das erste, was ich da hingeklatscht hab, und World War 3 schon
gezockt, nein, immer noch nicht, und ich bin überrascht, muss man ja sagen, SteamStats,
ich bin überrascht, dass das Game, äh, wo ist es denn, SteamStats, SteamStats, so mal
SteamStats-Puppgirr und setzen die App-ID von World War 3, ich bin, ich bin überrascht,
dass das Game, ähm, das hatte, das hatte so einen Mini-Hype am Anfang, ne, aber, also
das ist nicht schlecht, ja, also quasi die ersten Tage, ein bisschen Hype, aber dann
sehr konstant die nächsten Tage, das ist, das ist eigentlich gar nicht schlecht, im Vergleich
zu, ja, jetzt bist du noch da, im Vergleich zu, die haben so maßlos verkackt, ey, ich
meine, ne, guckt euch das mal an, das Game war echt ganz cool, als das rausgekommen
ist, und das hatte, muss man sich mal angucken, Peak-Players hier im Juni, hat das 104.000,
ja, und letztens 2.000, die haben so extrem verschissen in dem Game, der Wahnsinn, the
Fork, also unglaublich, wie man es da so verscheißen konnte, die hatten echt ein gutes Spiel-Prinzip,
ja, ein gutes System, auch bei dem Waffen-Craften und sowas, aber die haben es richtig verschissen,
ja, Spiel zu Red Dead Redemption 2, da hatten wir es gerade von, wir haben uns ja hier die
Metacritic-Scores angeguckt, da hatten wir es gerade von, ich bin wahrscheinlich der
einzige gefühlt, weltweit, der sich das Spiel nicht gekauft hat, aber sag mal so, ich bin
wahrscheinlich einer der wenigen weltweit, die sich für Games interessieren und viel
spielen und viel Spielzeit haben allgemein und sich Red Dead Redemption 2 nicht gekauft
haben, plus die noch eine Xbox One und eine PS4 haben, also ich meine, ich hätte ja alle
Möglichkeiten, mir den Kram zu kaufen, aber irgendwie, ich bin, ja, ich weiß nicht, kein
Open World Fan, was hältst du vom Forsaken-Bann, Moment, das sagt mir was, ich muss mal kurz
in mich gehen, das ist der Inder, oder, das ist der Inder, der Inder, der live on stage
gibt, ja, habt ihr das mitgekriegt Leute, es gab einen Turnier, ich glaube in Indien,
einen CSGO Turnier in Indien, und ein Typ hat live auf der Bühne, ja, on stage, gehackt,
habt ihr das mitgekriegt, übelst geil, der Typ hat echt Nerven, on stage, und das beste
ist, seine Hacks hießen Word.exe, das ist, das ist so richtig old school letztes Jahrtausend,
ja, habt ihr das mitgekriegt, Wahnsinn, also wie man so bescheuert sein kann, das beste
war ja, wenn man nachguckt, wenn man nachguckt, der Typ, der war, bevor ihn Optik unter Vertrag
genommen hat, ja, Clip, Clip, gucken wir uns gleich an, gucken wir uns gleich an, bevor
ihn Optik unter Vertrag genommen hat, war der schon mal gebannt für Cheats, und anscheinend
haben sie es dann irgendwie hingekriegt, dass er quasi entsperrt wird, bzw. der Bann verkürzt
wird, weil er angeblich ja gar nicht selbst gecheatet hat, sondern seinen Account verkauft
hat, und der Typ, der halt, dem er den Account dann verkauft hat, oder verschenkt, oder was
auch immer, der hätte angeblich mit dem Account dann gecheatet, also nicht er selbst, also
allein schon diese Ausrede, siehst du schon mal, dass da irgendwie was nicht ganz stimmen
kann, wir gucken uns jetzt mal kurz den, ja, das gucken wir uns jetzt mal an, das ist echt
geil, wie er guckt, wie er guckt auf, nicht Destiny, Destiny 2, ok, wir müssen, wir müssen,
wir müssen mal auf YouTube selbst haben, on stage ban, player caught on stage cheating,
ok, er meint, bla bla, bla bla, bla bla, hat er nochmal, hier, hier hat er einen Ausschnitt
von, soll ich mal angucken, seine Mitspieler checken das jetzt erst, ne, da, da ist er,
da ist er, jetzt kommt es hier so, ich lösche das, nein, geh weg, geh weg, geh weg, und
der Typ ist so, also ich bin ja sonst nicht gerne schadenfroh, ja, aber das ist einfach
komplett selbst verkackt, also, so wie seine Mails geschaut haben, wussten die das, na,
das würde ich da nicht, das würde ich so nicht reininterpretieren, der hat, man muss
sich ja mal überlegen, ja, also in dieser Region ist es schon eine große Chance, wenn
eine Organisation wie Optik aufnimmt, und der Typ hat quasi sein komplettes Team gefickt
im Endeffekt, weil die sind alle rausgeschmissen worden danach, obwohl natürlich vorher nochmal
klargestellt wurde, dass sie es nicht wussten, ach ja, und übrigens, man nennt es ja nicht
rausgeschmissen, sondern man hat ihnen gestattet, weiteren, wie könnte man das auf Deutsch
nennen, was sind Opportunities, Gelegenheiten, ja, also man hat seinen Spielern gestattet,
ihre anderweitigen Gelegenheiten zu verfolgen, ich hab auch gedacht, okay, das heißt übersetzt,
ihr habt sie rausgeschmissen, moin City, ja, genau, das ist halt hart, oder, guckst
euch mal an hier, die ganzen Admins dahinter, ja, und das Gegnerteam, Gegnerteam, LOL, LOL,
brrrr, es ist halt echt Failed, es ist genauso Failed wie Realmoyale, das hat sie auch übelst
verkackt, ja, gibt's schon, ooooh das ist so dumm, vor allem Word ho simpler.
Ich hab's jetzt, ich hab's jetzt schon zugemacht, ich glaub, da hatten sie sogar, ich glaube,
Ich glaube, da hatten sogar noch screenshots von wat.exe drin. Das ist wirklich, es ist so fail, da fällt mir gar nichts mehr dazu ein.
Was hat er denn für ein cheat, weiß man das keine ahnung. Weiß ich nicht.
Weiß ich nicht.
Wahrscheinlich, also wenn man sich die Videos angeschaut hat, hat er halt sehr auffällig geaimt. Ja, also quasi durch die
auch quasi, also wenn man
Also was man da gesehen hat, ist
wie malt man den paint, ich bin der krasse paint noob, wo ist der Stift?
Also wenn jetzt hier irgendwie Kiste ist
und Gegner steht hinter Kiste, das ist Gegner, krasse Mauskills
und man guckt halt hier drauf, also sprich hier ist Fadenkreuz
hier ist Fadenkreuz und Gegner springt
dann hat er quasi schon, bevor man den Gegner sieht hat er schon quasi den hier hoch geaimt bis man
also quasi, da konnte man den vorher gar nicht sehen, das war schon sehr auffällig teilweise.
Sie sind freiwillig gegangen worden. Ja, man gestattet ihnen ja anderen
Gelegenheiten zu verfolgen. Das ist immer so um die Ecke geschrieben für rausgeschmissen, ja.
Also entweder hat er eine Wallhand gehabt oder hat er halt
sich ergreifend, um es schön auszudrücken, etwas stärkeren AimAssist als die normalen Leute.
Ja, AimBot ist ja aus, ist ja out, heutzutage hat man AimAssist.
Das ist, äh, wahrscheinlich wenn du heute einen Cheater erwischt, dass er ja allerkrank Cheater macht AimBot aus, ich habe keinen AimBot, ich habe AimAssist.
Das ist besser. Opfer.
Also, wo sind wir denn jetzt eigentlich stehen geblieben?
Ich wollte euch die neue Meme-Tool-Version zeigen, beziehungsweise der Stand, wie weit ich bin.
Ähm, der hatte einfach einen DX Racer.
Zum Thema DX Racer, ich weiß nicht, ob ich schon mal uns zu ihm erzählt hab,
das wird wahrscheinlich wieder mehr Schwätz-Stream als, ähm, übrigens, äh, morgen machen wir die, machen wir, äh, Datmuss sei ja fertig.
Das, äh, ich hab nicht nur gelabert das letzte Mal, dass wir die Spiele, die wir anfangen, auch beenden, ja.
Ähm.
Ich hatte nämlich auch mal einen DX Racer-Stuhl.
Und zwar, ich muss jetzt mal gucken, welcher das gewesen ist, da kann ich euch nämlich zeigen, was, was da dran steht.
Nicht so dolle, wa? Racing-DX.
Moment, ich muss mal drauf gucken, der steht hier nämlich noch.
DX Racer, da steht aber nicht drauf, was es ist.
Schwarz-Weiß ist er, steht hier irgendwo drauf, was es für ein DX Racer ist?
Keine Ahnung, ne, steht nicht drauf.
Naja, zumindest ist es im Prinzip auch egal, es sieht...
Der sieht dem relativ ähnlich.
Aber, aber die Dinger sehen ja alle so aus. Also ich mach jetzt einfach mal stellvertretend den hier auf, ne.
Und, gibt's da, gibt's da vielleicht mal ein gescheites Bild von?
Ah, Gott.
Okay, kann man's größer machen? Ja.
Also, ähm, hallo, DX Racer, ich möchte es einfach mal in groß haben.
Ähm, das ist, ist ja schon eine Weile her, als, als ich den wirklich benutzt hab.
Ähm, weil ich kann den nicht mehr benutzen, denn, ich muss gucken, dass die Seite stimmt.
Ja.
Also quasi rechts, rechte Seite, ist komplett hier unten rausgerissen.
Also, das spricht für die Qualität von dem Stuhl, dass es überhaupt möglich ist.
Also mir fallen sonst keine, keine Stühle ein, wo das bauweise-bedingt überhaupt geht, dass ne,
dass ne Armlehne aus der, aus dem Rahmen reißen kann.
Das ist, das, das geht eigentlich gar nicht, aber DX Racer geht das, ja.
Und ich meine, der Stuhl ist irgendwie für 150 Kilo oder so ausgelegt.
Da bin ich noch ne ganze Ecke drunter.
Ähm, auch wenn der Max-Dicke-Arme hat, aber so viel hab ich trotzdem nicht.
Und da ist das hier komplett rausgerissen. Und seitdem hab ich mir gedacht, Scheiß auf irgendwelchen Gaming-Chairs oder sonst was.
Relativ bequem war er, er war halt wackelig, ja.
Wackelig und hat sich relativ billig angefühlt.
Also, ich kann jetzt nicht empfehlen, DX Racer zu nehmen.
Ja, und auch dieses, auch dieses Hinter, ähm, Hinterklappen war sehr bequem.
x-racer zu nehmen
Ja und auch dieses auch dieses hinter hinter klappen war sehr hakelig da hat sie eben so ein
So ein hebel dran wo man das und das machen konnte der nicht richtig eingerastet ist ganz komisches zeug also
nicht nicht zu empfehlen
Okay
Max so nommig okay ist ist das nicht ist das nicht quasi
Die x-racer 2.0 so nach dem motto
Ich glaube nicht ich glaube ich glaube nicht dass sie was taugen
Also der der all time klassiker ist ja immer noch ikea marcus
Das ist so wenn man sonst nicht weiß was dann ikea marcus
Den gaming desk habe ich euch schon mal gezeigt oder
Die typen die wollten dass ich oder wo wir gefragt haben ob ich nicht ihren gaming desk
Promoten kann den habe ich auch schon gezeigt oder
Ja ich glaube habe ich schon haben da haben wir uns schon drüber kaputt gelacht und ich muss ja sagen
Ich aus der stelle
Ich habe aus meiner sicht habe ich das recht fair gemacht ich habe ein paar fragen zurückgeschrieben so nach dem motto halt
Erfindet interessant euer produkt und ich habe da noch ein paar fragen zu ihr schreibt einfach auf eurer home page
Hergestellt in deutschland und von deutsch links und wer ist dann so das team dahinter und
So quasi was zeichnet der netz den tisch aus gegenüber normalen tisch also sprich was ist denn der verkaufskontent und was ist denn der verkaufskontent
Und so quasi was zeichnet der netz den tisch aus gegenüber normalen tisch also sprich was ist denn der verkaufskontent und so was
Hingeschickt nie wieder eine antwort erhalten
Wo ich mir denke so okay das scheint man von seinem gaming desk nicht so überzeugt zu sein zeigt noch mal her war nicht dabei
Wie hießen das ding
Desk
Der ultra desk ultra desk war das genau
Oh sie haben neue fotos jetzt jetzt auch mit gedrängt halte okay das ist neu das hatten sie das letzte war noch nicht
Aber das ding sieht immer noch genauso genauso wackelig und plastik style aus wie das letzte mal
Was für ein stuhl hast du dir nach dem dx-racer geholt
einen sedus mister 24
Leitwartenstuhl
Einfach, weil der name so geil ist und das echt richtig geiler stuhl ist aber viel zu teuer wenn man nicht
Also preisleistungsmäßig ist der neue ist der neue nicht zu empfehlen aber es ist echt gut
Ja also
Muss ich da noch wahrscheinlich gar nicht so viel dazu sagen
Und ich mein
Sie haben jetzt zumindest ihre sprüche weggemacht
Sie haben jetzt zumindest ihre sprüche weggemacht so hatten sie hatten am anfang irgendwie hier draufstehen
Irgendwie sowas wie nach dem motto in studien belegtes bestes tisch des sein oder sowas da hatte ich auch gefragt
Okay, auf welche studien beruft ihr euch denn
War mich einfach interessiert wenn man also sprich wenn jemand auf die seite schreibt so nach dem motto in studien dann kann man dann sollte
Sollte man doch auch mal fragen können in welchen studien
Keine antwort draufgekriegt und ich finde halt es sieht richtig
Wackelig aus und auch schon dass man hier durch gucken kann irgendwie und auch wenn das wahrscheinlich für kabels ist ich weiß nicht also
Für mich wirkt das wie was was man beim besten will nicht brauche
Und ich mein guckt euch doch mal die die füße an ist das steht doch nicht stabil das ding was wir haben denn
Wir haben den amazon refling für meinen stuhl
ernsthaft
Warum haben wir denn sowas?
Nice das ist baro was der alles weiß
Na okay der preis ist nicht mehr als nicht mehr ist nicht mehr abtodate der der bei amazon steht
Ich bilde mir einen meiner war ein war also meiner hat mein stuhl hat keine 2000 euro gekostet
Ich glaube der war ein ticken billiger aber also immer noch viel zu teuer aber ich glaube ich habe den damals irgendwie für 1300 oder so gekriegt
Weil aber als aktion war und habe ich mir gedacht okay
Wenn es schon mal günstig ist dann kaufe ich mir ein weil ich ich kannte den stuhl schon von vorher und der ist wirklich gut
Aber also der hier
Aber wie gesagt absolut keine empfehlung preisleistung
Da sieht halt das ist genau den den ich habe also auch mit auch auch in dieser kombi mit
Mit dieser mit dieser kopfstütze das gute daran ist halt
Und wie gesagt das ist jetzt ja in dem fall kein sehr laut ich kriege ja dafür nichts hätte ich nichts dagegen wenn ich dafür was kriegen will
Aber einfach nur weil ich den weil der stuhl gut ist und ich würde sagen das ist der beste stuhl den ich je hatte bisher und
Der ist wie neu
Wie neu ohne scheiß ich sitze jetzt darauf seit jahren schon mittlerweile weiß ich was ich gekauft habe vor
2013 bin ich umgezogen das heißt ich sag mal so fünf fünf jahre ungefähr oder so
Jetzt ja drauf ohne scheiß wie neu
Perfekt
bequem
ultra stabil
Also wenn sich einer einen stuhl der ein lebend lang hält kaufen will dann kaufte sich den
Also alle anderen kaufen sich am besten ikea markus weil
Das ist preisleistungsmäßig mit sicherheit die bessere alternative als der hier
So
Um mal weiter weil eigentlich war eigentlich wollte ich euch ja zeigen was es neu ist bei mimtool gibt nachdem wir ewig geschwätzt haben
hallo mehr enti 86
Was hast du schon von der neuen g wireless maus von logitech gehört die hat weniger millisekunden als eine kabel maus kostet 230
Weniger millisekunden als eine kabel maus
Also ich würde ja verstehen gleichviel aber weniger
Okay, das muss das das müssen wir uns einmal kurz angucken
Logitech
Wie heißt die
Flosen
Was sind was sind die richtigen die hier pro wireless gaming maus also ich mag ja logitech maus ich habe jetzt ja schon ein paar sachen durch
das
Für mich persönlich schlimmste war razor
würde ich mir nehmen holen an mäusen
hatte ich mal zwei deserter vor jahren die waren
Qualitativ sehr gewöhnungsbedürftig
Da hatte ich jetzt ja auch eine weile sorry die hatte mir zu wenig features davor hatte ich eine logitech 503 oder was das war die war mal zu schwer und jetzt habe ich seit einem jahr oder so eine g 403
Und mit der bin ich voll und ganz zufrieden
Das einzige was bei der g 403 noch ein bisschen zu verbessern war die g 403 die war auch ein bisschen zu schwer
Das einzige was bei der g 403 noch ein bisschen zu verbessern wäre ist das das man vielleicht das mausrad ein bisschen schwerfälliger
Einstellen könnte
h
Kabellose lightspeed technologie für profi gamer
speed technologie für profi game ja dass man wird dass man heutzutage eine
wireless maus bauen kann die
sagen wir so die die relativ geringe latenzen hat das bezweifle ich nicht
leitzung rgb ja voll jeder spiel der reste ist ziemlich logisch sein wie
wie läuft es mit aufladen weil das ist das was mir eigentlich bei wireless
mausen gewicht und aufladen ist das was mir
bisher bei wireless mausen auf den keks gegangen ist und ich also ich mag
persönlich halt leichte mäuse
ja fredi die hatte vorher auch die z2a die hatte ich zwischen der g 503
die gewalt ist überhaupt die g 503 ist kein traktor ja g 502 so die hatte ich
die z2 hdc 2a zwischen der g 502 und der g 403 logische bezeichnung die war mir
einfach zu schwer das ding das ist richtig fett die dicke maus 70 kramm das
ist echt ziemlich leicht
den maus per aufladen ok muss ich mir vielleicht mal angucken weil ich muss
sagen die logitech software die gefällt mir gut vor allem nachdem man da
wirklich makros basteln kann wie man will dass er komplette luar umgebung
dabei also man kann wirklich in logitech logitech treiber kann man
wirklich alles machen die 403 hat keine gewichte oder die
gewichte also falls falls ach hier unten hat so was ja aber das habe ich
rausgenommen ja ja hier ist kein gewicht drinne ich habe die hier gerade aufgemacht
die sind alle raus die gewichte die wie die wiegt nichts hier die die 403 ich
habe also ich mag leichte meiste da an der anlass des ganzen warum ich die g
502 nicht mehr haben wollte wie ich überhaupt
drauf gekommen bin ist das war die zeit wo ich meinen competitive overwatch
anfall hatte ja wo ich hier wo ich eine auf offer war sprach gemacht hat wo wir
auch muss man mal sagen ja für die zeit wo wir viel gespielt haben waren wir
auch wirklich nicht schlecht werden einfach weitermachen wissen wir hätten
einfach weitermachen was weil das lief nicht schlecht ich mein wir sind was
sind wir mal geworden top top acht oder so sonntags das war nicht schlecht wir
waren eigentlich auf dem guten weg zumindest dabei ist mir aufgefallen dass
ich mit der g 502 bin ich übelst faul geworden ja das war halt auch die zeit
wo ich ab und zu mal oft hängen und so was gespielt habe und wenn man wenn man
saria spielt da war es damals voll im trend dass man mit saria immer left click
right click gemacht hat also das war es war es quasi war es quasi gestrahlt mit
saria also mit dem laser strahlen zwischendrin immer rechts click bomben
ein eingestreut ja und dazu musste man schnell nach unten auf die füße der
gegner und wieder hoch und ich habe gemerkt ich mache das nie weil ich zu
faul bin die maus zu bewegen da habe ich mir gedacht leute es wird mal zeit
mit leichtere maus kaufen da muss man auch immer darauf achten so ein bisschen
was mir an der logitech software fehlt ist dass ich maus hoch runter nicht
einstellen kann wie maus hoch runter nicht einstellen
willst du das hoch runter links rechts ist oder was du meinst das mausrad oder du
meinst das mausrad der lusio max lusia genau da gab es einmal richtig geiler
da gab es richtig lustigen twitter post
da hat irgendeiner geschrieben so nach dem motto
wenn irgendwie einer sowas geschrieben wie die besten spieler der
jeweiligen helden so irgendwie keine ahnung dafran solscher geil sowieso geil
und da unten kommt dann irgendwie max lusio geil und darunter stand dann
irgendwie zwei zeilen später irgendwie ne ne nur spaß verarscht es war der
krasseste jebait überhaupt ich habe mich schon übelst gefreut dass endlich mal
einer meine lusio skills recognized ja danach kam dann an jebaited
ok jetzt haben aber ganz schön lange geschwätzt also ich zeige euch mal was
wir schönes neues eingebaut haben das ist schon viel weniger anfällig als das
letzte war also wir haben jetzt viele sachen auch schon eingebaut und
ordentlicher gemacht die setze mal noch sehr quick and dirty drin waren man
sieht das hier zum beispiel im vergleich vergleicht das mal mit dem
ersten das war überhaupt nicht aufgeräumt ja jetzt ist es sogar hier
wenigstens schön sortiert unterschiedlichen modulen ja wir haben die
webanwendung und die desktop anwendung haben wir getrennt und ich zeige euch das
jetzt mal also ich muss die datenbank noch löschen aus aus und ein paar
bildchen brauchen noch memes ein paar memes
zwei stunden installationsdauer auch das ist hart
zwei stunden das herrn auch zwei blu-rays das muss ich noch ausschalten kurz
ausschalten dass es nicht standardmäßig visible ist also
moment ich habe eingestellt dass es nicht standardmäßig visible ist ja geht
doch so also wenn man das das erste mal startet sieht das ganze so aus also das
kennt ihr ja noch das so sah das alte tool auch ungefähr aus in dem dreh ich
habe jetzt den button neu hinzufügen für hinzufügen erst mal hier oben dass
man nicht tracken tropfen muss immer hinzugefügt hierfür später für für
den extra obs browser hierfür theme wechseln und hier noch ein settings knop
aber das ist jetzt nichts neues die richtig coolen sachen kommen kommen wenn
man anfängt bilder rein zu ziehen und also für alle die jetzt die das noch
nicht kennen ja vielleicht soll ich noch mal also frage in die holen ist
jemand heute da der noch kein programmier stream von mir
gesehen und nicht weiß was das letztendlich gibt da kann ich das noch
mal kann ich aber kurz was dazu erzählen was eigentlich der anlass des ganzen ist
warum war das hier basteln
ok ganz viele ja gut dann erzählen also es ist ja so wenn man wenn man jetzt
hier zum beispiel obs ist und man macht einen overlay so was hier zum beispiel
dann seht das nur ihr also ich sehe das ja nicht das heißt wenn ich jetzt wenn
ich jetzt quasi in den bild einblende und vergesse es auszublenden fällt mir
das nicht auf dann sehe ich das schlicht und ergreifend nicht da muss ich drauf
warten bis einer im chat sagt machst du hast das bild noch eingeblendet
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht es wäre doch cool so ein bisschen wie elgato
stream deck allerdings ohne dass man extra hardware dafür braucht und vor
allem dass man letztendlich auch mehr damit machen kann ja weil man eigene
sachen einbauen kann dass wir ein tool basteln wo man quasi mit shortcuts sich
bilder als overlay anzeigen lassen kann
ich kann euch mal ich zeige euch mal die letzte version davon aber mal aus also
die erste unordentliche variante so da kannst du dann jetzt halt hier mit mit
shortcuts kannst du dir halt bilder als als overlay anzeigen lassen und vor
halt der große vorteil ist 0 4d bestes emote wo der vorteil ist dass ich sie
selbst sehe und das schöne an diesen bildern ist die sind man kann durch
klicken wie man hier sieht na ich kann durchklicken und selbst wenn ich die
bilder ein und ausblende es hat keinen einfluss auf irgendwelche
sachen die im fenster dahinter macht also die sind eigentlich ziemlich
transparent und interagieren mit nichts anderem
das ist eigentlich in uns weg der sache also zum beispiel wenn ich ein spiel auf
hab und ich drücke jetzt streuung l dann wird gelullt dafür ist was da das ist
aber noch die alte variante gewesen und am anfang habe ich ganz billig gemacht
ich habe einfach keine ahnung zwei waren im prinzip ausgedruckt auch nur zwei
seiten lang oder so was gebastelt was einfach ein ordner mit bildern einliest
und die bilder hießen halt wie die wie die tasten wie die shortcuts also die
tasten kombination immer mit mit steuerung dabei unter denen sie
erscheinen sollen also sprich wenn ich hier hot pocket ist dann steuerung 1 für
die ganzen feministen unter uns gaben ist f4 das war zwar super einfach zu
bedienen war aber auf dauer ein bisschen
nervig man konnte nichts gescheit hinzufügen ist gescheit entfernen und
irgendwann bin ich auf die idee gekommen wir könnten ja auch text to speech und
sowas einbauen und da ist diese sache hier ziemlich schnell an seine grenzen
gestoßen weil man kann man kann zum beispiel zu so einem bild keine
zusätzlichen informationen speichern ich kann weil ich alles quasi im
dateinnahmen drin stehen habe an information ich habe ich hatte keine
datenbank dahinter und nichts deswegen habe ich mir gedacht wir machen das
ganze mal ordentlich wir machen wieder ein ordentliches web interface dazu was
man auf dem zweiten rechner anmachen kann also sprich man startet das programm
auf dem ersten rechner und auf dem zweiten rechner macht man das web
interface an und kann auch von dort bilder anklicken wenn man sie nicht auf
irgendeinem shortcut hat oder sowas das ist den uns weg der sache dass man
overlays machen kann die man selber sieht und wir haben auch in obs ich will es
nicht plug-in nennen weil es ist nicht wahr wir haben auch nur oben in obs
funktion eingebaut dass man im obs quasi die bilder einbinden kann ohne
dass man sie selber sieht also dann quasi so ein bisschen wie elgato stream deck
plus ohne extra hardware ich habe eine riesen to-do liste was wir noch alles
einbauen können ja von rgp tastatur unterstützung bis
tatsächlich selbst stream deck integration aber jetzt zeige ich euch mal die
neue variante und wie das wie das da funktioniert
also wenn man das das erste mal startet wohlgemerkt das ist das web interface
davon das web interface ist natürlich nicht gedacht dass man das auf dem
gleichen rechner verwendet wie man streamt also das ist jetzt nur dass ihr
es seht das ist das web interface kann man auf einem zweiten rechner verwenden
oder auf einem tablet verwenden oder auf einem smartphone verwenden wo man dann
quasi remote draufdrücken kann was man für bilder hier anzeigen will ja so und
bis mir dann irgendwie aufgefallen ist ok wenn wir das ein bisschen ausweiten
wollen ja also wenn wir das ein bisschen verbessern wollen also dass man auch ein
bisschen text hier dazu speichern kann dass man text to speech einbauen kann und
und solche sachen da brauchen wir eine kleine sqlite datenbank im hintergrund
wo man die informationen zu speichern und wir brauchen vor allem eine
benutzerfreundliche art und weise wie man denn bilder hinzufügen kann weil
sagen wir so track and drop in irgendein ordner ohne weitere informationen ist
jetzt auch nicht so der weisheitsletzter schluss so und jetzt haben wir da halt
ein paar funktionen mehr im web interface also zum beispiel wenn man das
programm jetzt neu hat man muss es auch nicht installieren man kann sich einfach
runterladen auspacken und gut ist so und nimmt man sich einfach in den bild und
zieht es hier rein das kann man übrigens vom zweiten rechner aus machen
ja oder vom tablet aus machen ich zeige es euch jetzt hier nur auf dem
streaming rechner dass ihr es seht das web interface ist eigentlich für den
zweiten rechner gedacht ja zieht man dann hier rein job hier dann geht das
upload formula auf da kann man jetzt zum beispiel sagen hier hier name hock
jam text text keine ahnung um mega lull was auch immer ist eigentlich egal was
man da für den text eingibt das ist bloß dass man es einfacher finden kann
letztendlich oder wenn man text to speech machen will da kann man sich in
hotkey ausdenken so zum beispiel strom b das haben wir im letzten stream
übrigens gemacht dass man dass man hier capturen kann also ich tippe jetzt hier
nicht etwa control plus b oder sowas drin ist und ich drücke die knöpfe
control b control b control b und der capture das ja das ist eigentlich auch
ganz cool das funktioniert noch nicht so hundertprozentig
aktuell mapter die tasten nicht auf die richtigen tasten weil die keycodes von
javascript anders sind als die keycodes von wpf da muss ich mir noch was
überlegen wie wir das machen aktuelle steuerung b zum beispiel steuerung w aber
wahrscheinlich werde ich nicht den code übertragen sondern einfach lowercase
den buchstaben der gedrückt wurde da fällt mir schon was ein so jetzt kann man
noch auswählen ob man ich zeige es einfach so wenn man jetzt upload drückt
zack eigentlich sollte die formen dann zugehen übrigens hier ich kann das noch
favorisieren das ganze oder text to speech einschalten
wir machen jetzt mal zu und wenn ich jetzt hier drauf klicke dann ist pock
angesagt pockers ne pock champ nicht pocker pockers
so und dann jetzt könnte ich mir das auf dem tablet aufmachen
ist das nicht ein bisschen groß für smartphone warum smartphone
kommt auch von der größte ungefähr hin
ja oder oder hat mit shortcut also sprich ist es so gedacht wenn an dem
rechner wo ich streame kann ich es mit quasi den shortcuts die ich definiert
habe auslösen das bild oder aber ich kann es vom tablet oder vom zweiten
rechner aus halt über das web interface anmachen und ihr seht das ist übel
schnell da legt nix oder sonst was das ist instant da habe ich viel wert drauf
gelegt dass er nicht erst noch irgendwie ewig lädt weil nichts ist nerviger als
irgendwelche längenden die nicht passen mehr also wenn jetzt irgendwie was
geiles passiert drückstuhl wie beim und jetzt neues feature was wir heute
vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen ausbauen weil wir haben ja in einem der
letzten streams weep text to speech funktionen getestet wenn dein pc auf
englisch ist ist da nicht beim start auch der tastatur englisch im laut ich
habe eingestellt dass ich german key layout und englisch sprache kann man
gibt die app nur für enttäuschung ist keine app das ist das ist das ist eine
webseite da kann ich einfach drauf gehen guck mal also davon abgesehen dass da
jetzt lokel aussteht da müssen nicht lokel ausstehen da könnte auch eins zwei
punkt ich habe keine ahnung was meine ip ich glaube 164 nein ja aber da kannst
du natürlich einfach die ip von einem rechner eingeben und also macht keine
safari auf dem iphone auf und gibt es dann ein die ip von deinem rechner und
dann geht die webseite auf auf deinem smartphon
kann man auch die koordinaten einstellen wo das off-line erscheint
das kommt noch das ist noch nicht eingebaut aber sowas kommt dann
irgendwann mal in das settings menü rein habe ich mich auch schon überlegt das
wäre ganz praktisch wenn man das hier irgendwo platzieren könnte letztendlich
ja also wenn ich dann quasi sagen könnte ok ich will das in der linken
oberen ecke oder in der mitte oder sonst was in der richtung
ja also man braucht dafür überhaupt keine app das ist das ist eigentlich
viel besser als mehr weil du machst dafür den browser auf gibt auf die
adresse von deinem rechner also lokel aus vielleicht ist nicht sondern halt die
richtige adresse von einem rechner und gehst darauf muss ja auch so sein
letztendlich weil die bilder angezeigt werden sollen ja immer noch auf diesem
rechner hier so jetzt jetzt haben wir noch neuf funktion eingebaut habt ihr
gerade gesehen also nehmen wir uns mal hier eine runde monka es der braucht
übrigens ein bisschen im anzeigen weil der ist ein bisschen auf was heißt der
ist 4k also das ist ein 4k monka es also nicht etwa irgendein monka es
sondern ein 4k monka es ist das hier
fett x besser namen schön dass ihr das gefällt so soll ich feature zeige ich
mal ziehen wir rein übrigens das war ein riesen akt bis das funktioniert hat ihr
seht dass jetzt hier am kürzer move steht also sprich daran kann der user
theoretisch erkennen dass man hier sachen ablegen kann
move ok name egal wie ich nenne es ist so wie zum suchen hier die suche muss
übrigens auch noch einbauen für die suche hier oben ganz praktisch wenn ich
dann irgendwie 50 bildchen drin hab will ich vielleicht auch mal suchen was
sachen ist so und jetzt kann ich sagen text text da machen wir jetzt zum
beispiel hier irgendwie keine ahnung ich gruppiere mir einfach mal was aus dem
chat
ich gruppiere mein text aus dem chat hast du jetzt eigentlich gaming strom und
jetzt kann ich sagen ok ich will dass das nicht einfach nur ein bild ist sondern
ich hätte gerne dass das text to speech ist dann sage ich hier text to speech
aktivieren stimme nehmen wir die fall default ist die standard windows stimme
upload und jetzt kommt das ist halt weil ich englische das ist nach
systemsprache abhängig fast ja also sprich man kann jetzt auch text to
speech machen das natürlich ganz praktisch der rest ist noch nicht
implementiert es geht aktuell die default stimme die wie stimme die aber
das letzte mal versucht einzubauen also die die hier das gibt es dann hier wenn
man als stimme wie auswählt jetzt müssen wir noch implementieren das geht
nämlich über den japanischen text to speech service woran das dann abruft ja
und natürlich kann man auch sagen wenn man hier kein bild rein zieht man
möchte nur text to speech haben ohne bild ist ja wer kann es sein dass ich
progress sagen will ohne bild anzuzeigen ja boy next door dafür könnte
man das auch verwenden du kannst natürlich damit auch
verschiedene verschiedene sachen verstecken
im prinzip kann man damit machen was man will man kann ja auch bilder rein
ziehen was man will ja als animationen werden nur gibt es funktionieren das
kann ich gleich sagen also irgendwelche also richtige video clips werde ich
unterstützen das zu großer akt aber gibt es reichen ja
die gif das gif abspielen hat in der alten version schon funktioniert in der
neuen version funktioniert noch nicht aber das könnten wir eigentlich einbauen
jetzt oder eigentlich können wir das gif einspielen das gif abspielen wieder
einbauen weil das war kein großer akt hier machen wir text to speech aus
weil aktuell ihr seht er geht nicht er muft nicht das ist quasi ein
für eigentlich ganz so rare rarer parrot
aber man beachte was jetzt zum beispiel also wo sich jetzt zum beispiel schon
auszahlen dass wir das deutlich ordentlicher gemacht haben als das
letzte mal ist dass jetzt auch ohne größere hex diese aktivitätsanzeige hier
ordentlich funktioniert die hat ja das letzte mal schon immer rumgebackt ohne
ende in einer alten version was sind es ja unten eigentlich für
flecken
seht ihr die auch aber das das baume jetzt mal ein das war nicht schwierig ich
kann mich noch daran erinnern wie wir gucken uns jetzt einfach in der alten
version ab übrigens sobald die grundsätzlichen funktionen gehen kommt
es auf github genauso wie die aktuelle variante also kann sich jeder den
southscroll angucken ist nichts geheimes kann jeder kostenlos verwenden wie er
will bloß ich habe seit ihr seht ja schon ein paar monaten an der alten
version nichts mehr gemacht und noch nicht gepusht ich werde die dann auch
überbügeln aber wir haben hier eine historie das heißt man kann die sich
immer wieder angucken abgerade standbild ist das gewollt
ist kein standbild bei mir so wir gucken uns jetzt einfach mal kurz ab in der
letzten version wie ich das noch mal gemacht hat mit dem gif wpf animated
gif genau dann machen wir das doch jetzt mal wir bauen wir jetzt ein dass das
gif wieder animiert ist und danach bauen wir die suche wieder ein nutzt ihr geht
auch in der firma ja ich bin bei uns da hatten wir das letzte letztes team schon
was ich was ich auf der arbeit mache ich bin ja bei uns quasi der beauftragte
für für unsere software gepusht das heißt ich mache den ganzen tag eigentlich
nichts anderes wie geht im weiteren umfeld hast du dir gedanken über die
lizenz gemacht ja das ist das gibt hier was free beer license oder so was da
kann jeder mit machen was er will wann er will wor er will das ist mir ist mir
wurscht das einzige was ich vielleicht einbau ist dass man wie nennt sich das
attribution ne das man den namen nennen muss ja das vielleicht das einzige was
ich einbaue
so gucken wir mal so wie ging das jetzt noch mal müssen jetzt erst einmal sagen
wir müssen jetzt erstmal diesen komischen wpf gif animations ding wieder
installieren
zack aber ansonsten gibt es eine lizenz mit irgendwas vollkommen unspektakuläres
sein ja wo im prinzip jeder machen kann was er will
das brauche ich nicht mehr kommt weg auf warnung javascript warnung haut ab geht
weg original studio ist für javascript und so was übelst fail
deswegen mache ich das jetzt auch wieder haben wir das letzte mal auch schon mal
wieder mit visual studio code der das gännt zum beispiel der third party
libraries auf irgendwelche warnings total hängen geblieben ja wozu
epf animated gif ich gucke mir das jetzt einfach ab von dem was das letzte mal
gemacht haben so also also im prinzip muss ich jetzt gucken wenn das bild was
ich anzeigen soll wenn das den gif ist dann wird es eine animation und wenn das
kein gif ist wird es ein ganz normales bild wo haben wir es denn hier show gif
schau gif
ja probieren wir mal prinzipiell das funktioniert mit dem gif mal gucken jetzt
gehen natürlich die anderen bilder nicht aber ich hoffe dass gif geht
bevor bevor wir irgendwie was anderes einbauen gucken wir ob das geht da
parodiert er
was man sieht übrigens wie der ram verbrauch hoch geht wenn ich in 4k
bild anzeige wenn es jetzt ein paar minuten läuft geht es wieder runter
der garbage collector ist da nicht das schnellste sobald quasi die bilder aus
dem ram geflogen sind dann sind wir wieder über 140 mb jetzt geht auch die
gif animation
was macht text-to-speech aktuell ist das default windows text-to-speech text-to-speech
was dabei ist wie gesagt als nächstes text-to-speech engine werden wir die
einbauen für die riebs unter uns dass die auch die passenden text-to-speech
engine dran haben also im prinzip wie kriegen wir das jetzt am besten raus
eigentlich das billigste ist eigentlich ob wir gucken ob die datei eine gif
endung hat nachdem es eh nicht remote aufgerufen wird ist es eigentlich auch
egal ich setze ja festen gif endung wenn es ein gif ist bei mir hängt das stream
und bei mir hängt nix monka ist hängt bei euch noch irgendwo das stream
stream hängen so streben das ja was gibt dass das ist kein javascript das
frontend ist ja was gehabt hier ja was gibt geschwobbelt das frontend ist
ach so ja das ist das könnte ich eigentlich mal wieder den titel schreiben
das hat die letzte mal ja auch immer gemacht ans mann gleich weiß was sache
ist
schreibt das mal den titel rein
ich hoffe der titel aktualisiert demnächst beckern ist sie scharpe asb
dort net core frontend ist javascript und in dem fall in jr's jr's weil ich
eigentlich keine ahnung von javascript habe und zumindest nicht so gut und mir
das auf anhieb gefallen hat
so also wir gucken jetzt im prinzip ganz billig wenn der fahrt wenn wenn er
endet wenn er mit punkt gif endet dann wollen wir das hier machen
dann wollen wir wollen wir den gif anzeigen und ansonsten wollen wir im
endeffekt ja ansonsten wollen wir im endeffekt ganz normal das bild
eigentlich müsste es irgendwie so in der richtung funktionieren
hitler sagt weil die sind auch sehr nice
geht es kaputt warum geht das nicht was habe ich ver was habe ich vergessen
das problem hatte ich das letzte mal auch schon man muss fail man muss image
source auf null setzen ja genau total uns die scharp style mäßig muss man das
machen
äh moment
das ist ziemlich bescheuert benannt warte mal da pick mal nicht durch
wir nennen das einfach source source null blabla blabla
okay mal gucken ob es jetzt funktioniert
nee das mache ich hier verkehrt warum zeigt ihr mir das andere nicht an
muss ich da noch so komisches zeugs drumherum machen
warte mal ich bin ich bin verwirrt achso bin ich doof ich setze die source ja gar nicht
funktioniert
jetzt funktioniert es auch kaum macht was richtig geht also jetzt können
das funktioniert was geht das nicht bin ich aber das sind fünf zeilen
anscheinend bin ich gerade nicht dazu in der lage wo genau ist jetzt ist das
problem
probieren wir probieren es mal so ich glaube
ich meine letztes ist im prinzip genau das gleiche wie vorher was funktioniert
hat die bitmap ist leer ja ok aber ich setze die doch hier oder oder ist einmal
leer immer leer aber warum das nicht funktioniert ja das ist mich wundert
aber dass das so rum nicht funktioniert wenn ich sage ihm doch hier auch da
fahrt achso ich dachte mir source ist null oder ist es im prinzip egal ob ich
ihm danach noch mal in fahrt gebe woran das neu der lädt es nicht neu ok ja gut
das muss man wissen wenn man das weiß ist ok
da machen wir das so
ok jetzt funktioniert das auch max wann kommt auf youtube noch mal
auf erwarscht ich spiele aktuell kein auf erwarscht so gif animation
funktionieren wir da alles gut das wichtigste ist schon mal drinnen
gif um nicht zu sagen jiff wie die coolen leute das versuchen immer aus
zu sprechen gif das heißt aber nicht gif kennst du hofer am taunus ja
natürlich kenne ich das
jetzt
so ja das wollte ich aber eigentlich gar nicht machen aber es ist schön dass
es gibt die gifs auch funktionieren ich weiß eigentlich gar nicht so genau was
ich weiß ich heute uns die machen wollte weil letztendlich funktioniert es
mittlerweile ganz gut also wir müssen noch einen nicht wirklich installer weil
installer ist es nicht wir müssen noch ein package draus bauen dass man sich
drunter laden kann und einfach ausführen ja und dass man dann kein ordner und
packen muss mit 500 dateien oder so moment
also habe ich jetzt wieder verkehrt gemacht
das war so ganz merkwürdig
ja wir machen also ein mini installer draus also was wo man keine admin
rechte oder so drauf braucht
prinzip einfach was was mich runterladen kann anklicken dann installiert sich
das hat nämlich auch den großen vorteil dass man update notifications machen
kann was so sonst ein bisschen nervig ist wenn es nicht wenn man das selbst
bauen muss also sprich dass es dann immer ab und zu mal nachguckt nach dem
motto gibt es eine neue version und dann beim starten quasi anzeigt hallo wenn du
eine neue version haben willst dann laden wir runter
so eine sache die wir jetzt noch einbauen können jetzt müssen wir leider
wieder mit den java script zeug basteln ist die suche spielt sich noch call of
uninstall ab und zu mal tatsächlich die suche weil aktuell macht die suche
nix so und wenn man sich jetzt überlegt man hat hier mehr als ein bild also man
hat hier irgendwie keine ahnung 50 bilder drin da kann es ja sein dass man
mal danach suchen möchte shortcuts gehen übrigens auch automatisch wenn man
neu startet
und die suche macht dann auch nichts wenn ich jetzt hier nach it suche zeigt
doch nichts anders können wir jetzt noch können wir jetzt noch einbauen
übrigens die informationen was es für bildchen gibt und auch der text to
speech text der liegt hier in einer sql datenbank also man braucht eigentlich
überhaupt keine abhängigkeit dafür dass man verwenden kann
das ist auch wichtig ja genau ich wollte jetzt auch suche einbauen also dann
müssen wir doch als erstes mal wir gehen jetzt mal ins html rein übrigens wenn
ihr irgendwas wissen wollt was weiß ich zu programmieren technik aktuelles
zeug ihr könnt alles ins chat schreiben ich habe das hier am 2 monitor auf ich
sehe alles und die streams solche streams sind immer sehr gechillt alles
ja also da habe ich auch genug zeit wenn es manchmal bisschen untergeht wenn ich
irgendwann spiele kann ich schon das ein oder andere übersehen aber heute ist
wirklich alles kein problem
google suche plus google bilder download wäre nice habe ich mir auch schon
aufgeschrieben ist auch einen feature was auf der liste steht heißt nicht
dass wir sie in nächster zeit einbauen werden aber es ist auf jeden fall
angedacht hast du hättest du mal bock life is strange zu zocken nope so suche
wusste unser navigationsmenü da klick open pop
was navigationsmenü input das können wir uns auch das können wir uns auch
abgucken wie wir das letzte mal gemacht haben weil da haben wir sowas ähnlich
ist ja auch schon eingebaut da muss ich nicht sauber machen input
war was hier input da type text model filter ja das müssen wir noch machen
sonst kackts ab wir müssen den view sagen dass wir noch einen filter haben
wollen so und jetzt gucken wir mal wenn ich
jetzt was hat ttp in einem html kommt sofort ttp watt hobby überhaupt kein
problem überhaupt kein problem und ich behaupte mal die meisten um nicht zu
sagen zumindest die besten haben das alles selbst gelernt also ich kenne
viele die haben probleme damit die vorher keine ahnung hatten jetzt erst in der
uni anfangen das ist eher so eine so eine ja so eine
sache im kopf ja wenn es einem liegt dann merkt man dass schon früher oder
später selbst habe ich den eindruck und es gibt ja mittlerweile muss man auch
mal sagen es gibt ja auch auf youtube und auf im internet generell es gibt so
viele gute tutorials und ressourcen wie nie zuvor wenn man programmieren lernen
möchte ist das eigentlich die beste zeit man sollte sich immer überlegen was
man eigentlich genau machen will dementsprechend richtet sich so ein
bisschen nach dem mit was man am besten anfängt weil es ist immer so wenn man
ein bisschen was vor augen hat was man machen will dann motiviert das auch mehr
wenn man sieht dass man dass man ja sich der sache nähert ja also wenn ich jetzt
quasi keine ahnung
was weiß ich habe nen battlefield server und möchte eine statistik seite
machen für hatten wir ja mal können euch daran erinnern da nicht nur eine
seite gebastelt so eine statistik seite da ist ja ein battlefield server hatte also
manchmal möchte sowas machen für die leute die immer auf dem server spielen
irgendwie mit pp dann sollte man am besten mit pp anfangen einfach aus dem
grund weil man dann schneller was sieht von dem was man haben will
wenn man es selbst hostet oder den server hat der was anderes unterstützt
dann vielleicht auch eine andere sprache ich würde immer damit anfangen wo man
selbst direkt was sieht von also es hat meiner meinung nach keinen sinn wenn man
jetzt sagen wir sagen wir man möchte irgendwie so eine irgendwie eine kleine
windows desktop anwendung basteln sowas wie den taschenrechner hier wobei
taschenrechner wohlgemerkt das ist von der oberfläche her einfach in drinnen
ist nicht einfach wenn man sowas zum beispiel basteln mit nur den
grundrechner dann hat es keinen sinn wenn ich irgendwie mit python oder ruby
unter linux anfangen weil davon kriege ich keine moderne windows desktop
anwendung also ich würde immer mit dem anfangen was es mir halt was bringt
ja ja es ist so man kann aktuell tutorialmäßig so viel lernen wir noch
nie und ich ich sag immer wenn mich einer fragt so nach dem motto was so die
sprachen zum anfangen was am besten ist gibt es sind eigentlich bei mir sind
eigentlich so die üblichen verdächtigen die ich empfehlen kann das erste ist wie
gesagt man muss sich überlegen welche richtung man machen will aber so durch
die bank weg wo man auf jeden fall nicht verkehrt läuft ist aktuell mit
scharp dort net core oder dort net allgemein das bringt wird das miem tool
open source ja es ist aber so es ist ja wie du es ist ja schon open source
das ist ja schon hier auf github das ist zwar nicht die version wo ich gerade dran
basteln aber die kommt da auch hin
das ist noch die vorläufer variante die zwar noch ein bisschen einfacher
geschrickt ist aber halt an manchen stellen schon ein bisschen ein bisschen
rumbackt
ja also ich finde wenn man man kann mit mit dort net und und sie schafft
eigentlich relativ wenig falsch machen das läuft mittlerweile überall ja das
läuft unter liegungs oder merck unter winnows wenn man jetzt natürlich gui
programmer machen will also so irgendwas mit grafischer benutzer oberfläche dann
muss man sich nach was anderem aktuell und cross-platform winnows und die
scharp das beste was man machen kann wenn er noch merck und liegungs dabei
sollen dann zumindest aktuell noch nicht aber macht damit nichts falsch weil das
eine sehr schöne konsistente sprache in sich ist obwohl die eigentlich schon
ganze ecke älter ist also nicht ganz so alt wie java aber java ist auch keine
schöne sprache sie schafft dafür schon finde ich zumindest und damit macht man
auf jeden fall nichts verkehrt da geht ein weniger die sprache auf den sack als
bei anderen sprachen und man kann sich aufs lernen konzentrieren also ich finde
sie scharf ist zum einsteigen auf jeden fall nicht schlecht und das nächste ist
was wo ich finde was ich auch gut zum einstieg eignet ist pyson oder ruby
dann so ein bisschen was einem besser liegt zukunftssicherer ist auf jeden fall
mit pyson und alternativ natürlich auch javascript wenn man webseiten machen
will oder web anwendung oder sowas und eine sache die immer unterschätzt wird
aber wo ich der meinung bin die ist wichtig für alle die was in dieser
richtung machen ist basch also in der x beliebige x beliebige linux shell das
bringt richtig was wenn man auch nur entfernt damit was zu tun hat und es ist
egal ob man heute programmiert ob man was administriert ob man defops ist wie
das so schön heißt oder sonst was linux shell lernen ist auf jeden fall die
beste investition in der richtung wie man so machen kann
so wo sind verstehen geblieben hier blablabla filter filter hier so also was
wir jetzt machen wollen was auch relativ einfach ist weil wir haben das in der
alten version schon gemacht ich kann das jetzt mehr oder weniger copy pasten wir
wollen dass wenn ich hier oben nach itz suche nur noch hier der eingeblendet wird
der itz im namen hat oder zumindest irgendwo itz enthält dass der halt on
the fly sucht aktuell sucht er nämlich noch gar nicht so und deswegen müssen
wir das ganze filtern sagen wir hier filter
also übrigens auch sehr schönen java script die seit seit dem letzten
standard hat man hier auch so eine ordentliche lambda funktionen
geschichte also wie heißt genau wie heißt noch mal genau ich hab es mir
gerade irgendwie komme ich gerade nicht drauf diese lambda sonntags hier
ach keine ahnung man kann zumindest schön inline funktionen schreiben ohne
dass man jedes mal function da vorschreiben muss man früher in java
script war es ja so dass du im endeffekt bei jedem mist function hinschreiben
musstest das finde ich so jetzt deutlich schöner
swift ja swift ist auch nicht verkehrt ja wenn man weil man auf mech sachen
steht aber das schöne ist halt wenn man mit so was anfängt wie sie schabt die
sprache hat halt richtig relevanz auf allen plattformen und sie ist sehr
vielseitig ja sie hat eine gewisse funktionaler seite der objekt orientierte
seite man lernt dort nett was auch eine sehr wichtige plattform ist vor allem
lernt man programmieren und nachdem sie schabt zwar quasi wenn man sie schabt
kann man sich in jeder sprache jetzt mal von den funktionalen geschichten
abgesehen wenn man das kann findet man sich dazu recht also ich finde das ist
eine super sprache zum einstieg und das schöne daran ist dass man eben halt auch
nicht jetzt einfach lernt und da die sprache kann und mit der sprache nichts
anfangen kann man kann mit sie schabt letztendlich alles machen das einzige
was man sich nicht machen kann zumindest nicht gut machen kann sind
mac und linux desktop anwendungen das ist eigentlich alles sonst kannst du
alles machen von web anwendungen für alle möglichen betriebssysteme von
kommandoseiten tun für alle möglichen betriebssysteme mobile geschichten
alles wobei ich da auch was anderes nehmen würde aber es geht das einzige
wo es mehr schlecht als recht geht sind mac und linux desktop anwendungen aber
vielleicht kommt ja da was noch vor microsoft muss wir mal gucken
was sagst du zu c++ wenn es um reine performance geht oder aber um
irgendwelche ich finde ich finde lowlevel ist immer so ein bisschen blödes
wort aber wenn es wenn es halt um
ja wie sage ich das wenn es wenn es nicht lowlevel ist ich finde lowlevel
trifft es halt nicht wirklich ja also sprich wenn man wenn man andere sachen
ansprechen muss die sagen wir mal in c und c plus plus programmiert sind und
wenn man wenn es einem hauptsächlich auf performance ankommt und wenn man die
kontrolle ist das ist ein schönes wort dafür ja und wenn man die volle
kontrolle drüber braucht wann was passiert und wie genau da ist c++ nicht
schlecht für ansonsten nehme ich persönlich abstand von c plus plus weil
auch mit den neuesten standards das ist zwar deutlich schöner als in in alten
c plus plus varianten aber ich finde c plus plus immer noch keine schöne
sprache an sich c plus plus besteht sehr viel aus hier spitzen klammern und
dings und hier und teilweise uns an stellen und und ja die natürliche
taktisch alle irgendwie sind ergeben aber schön sind sie nicht
kannst du ja war und wenn ja warum gefällt es dir nicht ich kann kein java
also ich kann java lesen ich könnte java auch schreiben aber java ist eine
sprache die ich nicht mag gegen java habe ich eine abgrund tiefe abweigung
ohne dass ich jemals viel was in java gemacht habe
also kennst du ein gutes tun um in uns zur bala dark team einzurechnen
keine ahnung ich habe aber kein spezielles tool und das ist ziemlich
dark
kennst du scratch
max achtest du stark auf die konzert konzepte der objekt auch das jetzt
jetzt wird aber philosophisch stark auf die konzepte der objektorientierung oder
lieber quick in dort die mir ist das wichtig dass es ordentlich ist
allerdings
ist objektorientierung auf teufel kommen raus nicht unbedingt immer die
sinnvollste variante
ich wusste überlegen aber das irgendwie irgendwie ein beispiel beispiel zu
einführen ja also was beispielsweise in java sehr beliebt ist dass man für jeden
scheiß irgendwie eine factory in den factory manager klasse und hast du nicht
gesehen hast das heißt dann siehst du solche dinge hier wie wie irgendwie keine
ahnung factory manager of factory design manager create
blas sonst was und das mag zwar im sinne der objektorientierung ganz dolle
sein aber einfach unglaublich umständlich
ich bin auch jemand der sagt globale varianten sind grundsätzlich nicht
schlecht
sinnvoll eingesetzt und jetzt passt mal auf jetzt welches welches ganz
kontroverses loslassen sogar go to hat seine da seins berechtigung
da werden jetzt eigentlich wieder schreien
aber ich finde es gibt auch in modernen programm und programmier sprachen
anwendungszwecke für go to
soll ich mal ein beispiel sagen wo ich denke dass go to sinnvoll ist ich habe
ich kriege das aus dem kopf was jetzt gescheites hin
was hat es eigentlich mit omega 0 auf sich checkt das nicht omega das ist ein
emote
das ist bei der twitch tv emote
es gibt leute was
es gibt leute dass funktionen nicht mehr als drei returns enthalten sollten und
du redest von go to
du meinst es gibt leute die sagen dass funktionen nicht mehr als drei returns
enthalten soll nur jetzt von go to unter anderem gerade für sowas ist das gut zum
beispiel also wir gehen jetzt mal von aus wir hätten jetzt keine ahnung wir
hätten jetzt ein paar arrays ja wir hätten jetzt irgendwie so ein
dreidimensionales array oder irgendwie sowas haben wir haben jetzt hier nur mal
so exemplarisch so wir haben jetzt irgendwie vorschleifen vorschleifen
vorschleifen vorschleifen soll das wird uns durch unsere arrays raus durch
unsere arrays durchlaufen und wenn ich jetzt an dieser stelle hier sage wenn ich
jetzt hier eine abbruchbedingungen drinne habe ja also wenn jetzt zum
beispiel irgendwie die die der counter hier drinnen von dieser schleife gut ich
sollte jetzt mal so schreiben dass man zumindest kompilieren kann also wie dann
haben wir hier keine ahnung dann haben wir hier was haben wir hier so x beste
beste namen vorne hier haben wir vollkommen egal mal angenommen ich habe
jetzt hier die abbruchbedingungen dass wenn ich sage z ist gleich ich jetzt mal
rein fiktive sache ja break allerdings break hierhin wie mache ich das
gescheit
es gibt fälle da hast du nun mal einfach ein paar arrays wurde halt oder was
paar genäste das schleifen wurde im fall der fälle wenn du feststellst in
der innersten schleife ist jetzt soweit dass ich raus muss dass ich dann
abbrechen will ja gut das einfachste wäre ich macht eine
funktion draus und sagt dann hier drin return da bin ich auch raus das
funktioniert aber angenommen ich will das nicht weil logisch gesehen der
funktion auf was dahinter kommt dann ist es vollkommen legitim meiner ansicht
nach dass ich an dieser stelle go to verwende dahin ich finde go to das ist
eines der wenigen fälle wo ich sagen würde dafür ist es legitim und
eigentlich dann wenn man nicht nach oben springt also wenn ich jetzt sagen würde
go to da würde ich sagen oder das ist fail das geht kaputt oder check keiner
oder ist kacke aber so wenig ist es ok weil die alternative wäre ja im
endeffekt ich würde ich müsste so was hier machen so buhl buhl was weiß ich
ent falls dann würde ich dann hier drinne sagen end true und da müsste ich
dann quasi hier nachgucken if end break if end break das das ist nicht das ist
nicht wirklich schön kann man schreiben
vielleicht sollte man das auch nicht in java skript machen sondern in sie
schaft was funktioniert
ja klar es gibt es gibt verschiedene varianten wie gesagt ist das einfachste
wer macht sie eine funktion und geht damit die turn raus das funktioniert
auch aber sollte man den fall der fälle haben an dieser stelle finde ich ist
go to ok das war es aber auch so ziemlich ein verhandlungsfeld man ist
nicht ein
welche sprache benutzt du kran also dass das ist da jetzt bin ich gerade im java
skript feilen weil wir eigentlich die dass das input fell zu der suche um
funktionen wollten das programm ist aber aus einer mischung aus backends ist
sp.net also ist die schaft sp.net und sp.net core soll jetzt neu und das
frontend ist html java skript view js wenn du was wissen willst hau raus ich
bin heute eh mehr am labern als wirklich am programmieren alles muss auch mal
sein kann man hoch scrollen ein paar sachen übersehen mein favorit war bis
jetzt manager manager ja das ist das ist typisch java das ist typisch java da
sieht man so dinger ja manager manager create manager singleton class of
manager so sowas hast du das ist typisch java und deswegen mag ich ja war nicht
natürlich hängt immer letztendlich vom programmieren aber muss nichts hässliches
machen den java was ist halt kuh wie finde ich dahingehend ganz schön auch
er sprach auf der auf der java vm heißt haus heißt jvm auch eigentlich java vm
java wird schon mit schien ja ok heißt tatsächlich beste sprache um gämse
programmieren unity und sie schabt wenn man wenn es darum geht tutorial
einsteigerfreundlichkeit von allem was ich bisher gesehen habe unity und sie
schabt ansonsten wenn das um in den in den triple a bereich geht wo wo eigene
sachen verwendet werden da ist es zu 99 prozent c++ mit mich würde es nicht
wundern teilweise bestimmt noch hardcoded handcoded sampler teilweise
drinne aber games kommt einfach auf die letzten quäntchen performance in manchen
stellen an aber da wird das größte wahrscheinlich in c++ sein aber so in
punktu einsteigerfreundlichkeit und tutorials und verfügbare ressourcen
würde ich sagen unity mit sich haben
übrigens gibt ein cooles ein cooles 2d framework für sie schabt wenn wenn
wenn einem unity zu viel ist also habe ich sehr viele gute sachen von monogame
gehört bisher
so aktuell letzte version kam raus und es sind auch ein paar spiele die man
kennt mit monogame programmiert
also es gibt auch schon ein paar spiele in monogame also ist jetzt nicht so dass
man da du welle zum beispiel ist in monogame dass das keiner verwendet oder
so also für 2d sachen habe ich nur gutes von monogame bisher gehört aus wie
schabt in dem fall
und bevor jetzt einer wieder ankommt und sagt a null unity es gibt so viele
spiele mittlerweile in unity und auch große bekannte games in unity die gut
funktionieren funktionieren teilweise millionen leute spielen also man sieht
dass geht
ja smart sehe ich auch so ich halte aber auch nicht aus
regie 54 ich würde gerne mit programmieren anfangen und schauen schauen
mir gerade um womit ich anfangen könnt ihr du was empfehlen
ja da hatten wir es gerade von was möchtest du denn machen hast du eine
vorstellung davon was du machen willst so in die richtung ja möchtest du web
anwendungen machen also webseiten und interaktive webseiten ein bisschen was
machen kann möchte webseiten machen möchtest du
desktop anwendungen machen möchtest du server anwendungen machen
willst du kommandos anwendungen machen willst du eher mek linux windows machen
was willst du machen das ist so ein bisschen die entscheidung auch was man
mit was man am besten anfängt
habt das projekt bis jetzt nicht verfolgt könntest du mal kurz und knapp
erklären was das programm können soll ja ich kann es dir zeigen
ich muss so gucken dass ich gerade nicht kaputt gemacht habe
das hat jetzt nicht funktioniert
oh ich habe es kaputt gemacht
moment wo habe ich den sündungsfehler jetzt drin
sündungsfehler
sündungsfehler wo habe ich den sündungsfehler fabriziert hier drinnen
nicht oder ich zeige dir gleich was es macht ich habe irgendwas irgendwo ist
kaputt gemacht ok du kannst damit overlays anzeigen lassen bilder overlay
bilder das web interface ist jetzt nur exemplarisch auf dem rechner wo ihr
dass ihr es seht das web interface ist eigentlich gedacht dass du dir jetzt auf
dem tablet oder auf dem smartphone aufmachst und dort die bilder an tabs
ist im prinzip ein bisschen wie elgato stream deck bloß dass du keine
hardware verbrauchst ja du machst hier quasi das hier auf dem smartphone auf und
wenn jetzt gerade was geiles passiert dann kannst du für deinen stream einen
poggers einplatten und text to speech machen wenn du willst oder auch sein
lassen ja du kannst jetzt neue bildchen hinzufügen
kannst du sagen neues bild text text to speech an mit weep text to speech
normal text to speech du kannst auch ein hotkey machen mit steuerung w kann ich
das jetzt einplanen also sprich ich kann dann am streaming rechner kann ich
memes einplanen oder halt vom tablet aus oder vom zweiten rechner aus über das
web interface und das schöne daran ist dass die bilder nichts beeinflusst guckt
ich kann durchklicken und auf und zu machen und es passiert nichts also
sprich ich kann jetzt auch was spielen und die bilder als overlay nehmen ohne
dass es mich rausreißt das einzige was nicht geht natürlich ist fullscreen
fullscreen exklusiv fullscreen da geht das nicht
also habe ich jetzt irgendwas übersehen zockst du heute noch was
wahrscheinlich nicht aber wir machen morgen dark messiah fertig also ich habe
jetzt letzte mal nicht nur euch gebetet wo ich gesagt habe wir machen die games
auch wirklich fertig haben noch drei vier stunden dann sind wir damit auch
durch das schöne ist ich habe auch gewisse
motivation die games dann immer alle fertig zu machen weil alle games die ich
hier aufgeschrieben habe die man lieber spielen können zählen mit zu meinen
lieblingsgames deswegen ist es eigentlich kein stress das wollte ich
alles schon mal wieder spielen
womit wohl rettet redemption zwei programm ich bin so ich bin ein bisschen
hinten dran mit dem chat ich hab gleich aufgeholt womit wird wohl rettet
redemption 3 programmiert sein rockstar intern wahrscheinlich c++ gehe ich mal
von aus
das gta für gta gab es doch gab es keine keine mods wo man selbst programmieren
musste ich vermute mal c++ relativ sicher eigentlich
kurze frage wie soll ich mein pferd in rettet redemption 2 nennen ich bin für
jebaited für scharp alle die mit scharp anfangen wollen gibt es übrigens super
buch wem bücher mehr liegen als video tutorials der kann sich kostenlos das
galilio open book für scharp angucken das ist wirklich sehr umfangreich und
deckt alles wichtige und alles auch mittelwichtige ab also wenn man hier
durch ist hat man soweit den überblick dass man eigentlich alles machen kann
und es ist kostenlos das ist hat auch nur schleppische 1.402 seiten also
it's as fuck aber es reichen im prinzip schon die
ersten fünf die ersten zehn kapitel oder so da blickt man so gut durch dass
man eigene sachen machen kann das geht relativ schnell bisschen bis der wende
wenn es richtig auf anlegst bis in zwei drei tagen in so weit fit wende schon
mal ein bisschen was gemacht hat in der richtung dass er da kein ding
ja sehe ich auch so kastell an keine ahnung was leute in unity haben ich sage
wenn leute wenn wenn leute sagen mit unity gibt es noch scheiß games und
games die keiner spielt sag einfach hardstone also ist unity hat so dürfte
wahrscheinlich das meist gespielte unity spiel sein denke ich mal fällt
gerade kein anderes ein aber hat es auf jeden fall auch mit dabei ich brauche
einen einsteiger für asp asp.net koch überlegt hat ich habe ja vorher auch
bevor ich hier angefangen habe mit ich habe ja auch nichts mit asp.net koch
gemacht also was was super ist ist was da das kannst du die hand gucken das ist
direkt von microsoft es ist ein bisschen langatmig ja also das finde ich ist
nicht das beste die dinger sind ganz cool zumindest für so ein überblick und
ansonsten was was mir immer hilft ist auf youtube nein kein kirby ist immer die
aktuellen bild talks von microsoft die erzählen zwar da immer was aktuell ist
aber nachdem sie das immer anhand von einem beispiel machen kommt man
eigentlich ganz gut dahinter ja jetzt zeigen sie mal signal er verwendet was
wir hier auch als grundlage haben für die kommunikation back-end frontend also
die echtzeit kommunikation das hilft mir immer und ansonsten einfach youtube
oder gibt es bestimmt so viel und vor allem die microsoft kurse sind ganz cool
ja die haben ich mittlerweile offizielle kurse und das ist echt ganz cool also
da gibt es genug mittlerweile ist das was ich meine es ist mittlerweile so
einfach wie noch nie reinzukommen
das was bei asp.net koch halt so ein bisschen bisschen schwierig ist am
anfang zu checken es gibt verschiedene konzepte da drin also das sind das sind
im prinzip sind das quasi so 23 web frameworks in einem ja du hast diese mvc
geschichte also model view controller du hast quasi in den view das ist ein
html du hast ein model das ist da wo die logik drin steckt du hast einen
controller das da wo die logik drin steckt du hast ein model das ist das was
der datenbank gespeichern wird dann hast du allerdings noch das single page
application template und du hast noch das razor page template also aber ich
würde sagen mvc ist so dass das dass das wurde es hier auch übrigens drauf
aufsetzt so dass der standard ja
habe gerade schon mit dem chat geschrieben würde mich gerne anders moden
von spielen heran trauen und kleine programme script schreiben die einem
etwas leben erleichtern nach meinem abitur würde ich gerne informatik
studieren oder die richtung game programmieren gehen wir wurden vom chat
gesagt die scharpe und pausen oder kannst du kannst du nichts mit falsch
machen vor allem game programmierung ist die scharpe ein ganz guter einstieg
weil es hier plus plus im prinzip zu jeden abschreckt am anfang und auch
eigentlich nicht notwendig ist wenn man was mit unity macht und ich bin ich weiß
gar nicht was man wie es also cry engine ist wahrscheinlich ziemlich sicher viel
c++ gefunden aber an wie er hat ja diesen eigenen logik editor drinne wo man auch
nicht mal so viel selbst programmieren muss aber ansonsten weiß ich nicht in
was in was macht man die logik in in unreal weiß dass jemand ich vermute mal
c++ aber unity ist deswegen wahrscheinlich auch so beliebt gerade
weil es sich ab programmieren kannst früher konnte man in juni kommen mit
programmieren das war so was eigenes aber das haben sie mit der eingestampft
ich habe in der uni excel makro programmierung gelernt was kann man
damit anfangen ja für office zeug kann man damit schon
was anfangen also programme kann man damit nicht programmieren
eigenständige programme ist ja logisch ist ja in excel drinne aber ich muss
sagen um jetzt mal was positives über excel zu sagen ihr wisst ja ich bin
überhaupt kein fan von irgendwelchen office programm
ich finde vom ganzen office paket vom ganzen microsoft office paket das
einzig sinnvolle programm dabei ist excel wird braucht kein mensch powerpoint
braucht kein mensch visio da würde ich tatsächlich dem weg an wenn du
vorzieht wenn es so was sein muss exus braucht keine sau was da noch so dabei
excel oder das war es was ist was ist da noch dabei
was da noch dabei wo skype vor bussiness alter hör mal auf woodface
war not war das auch noch ganz gut aber brau aber sonst ist excel eigentlich
das einzige mit daseinsberechtigung ist ein stream pc dein home server oder ein
alter pc also aktuell streame ich und spiele ich auf dem gleichen pc ich habe
eben dran noch meinen alten rechner an der macht aber gerade nichts weil das
ding hier schlicht und ergreifend leistung ohne ende hat das sind 8700 kam
mit 1080 da muss ich nicht das gefrickel machen mit mehreren rechnern so jetzt
bin ich mit dem chef glaube ich bin da fast durch kannst du kurz erklären
welche nachteile man hat wenn man nur die visual studio community edition hat
gegenüber den anderen zwei versionen ich muss dir ehrlich sagen ich habe keine
ahnung früher konntest du keine addons verwenden das war die große beschränkung
bei und ich glaube kein team safe und so was verwenden aber was war wer will das
schon verwenden bei den alten studio versionen aber bei den neuen ich habe
keine ahnung es gibt keine einschränkungen einschränkungen die
mich nerven würden
kommst du rein von dem black ops wie du siehst 40 also fühlt sich trotzdem auf
das war nice hängt nicht hinter excel macro auch einfach vb keine ahnung was
man excel macros bastelt bestimmt irgendeinen visual basic dialect das ist
microsoft die haben in einer zeit lang unglaublich auf visual basic gestanden
gott sei dank sind die zeiten vorbei
die
Warlords und eingeschleift werden?
Äh, ernsthaft?
Aus dem Baro, das ist natürlich
essentiell, ja.
Wirst du Majority lernen?
Ich hab keine wirklichen Ambitionen,
was Spiele programmieren angeht.
Bei mir ist es immer so,
ich brauch ne Idee
für irgendwas
und dann guck ich mir an,
was man dazu braucht.
Das heißt, wenn ich ne super krasse Game-Idee hab
in nem Rahmen,
den man auch alleine umsetzen könnte,
was schonmal schwierig wird meistens,
dann hätt ich die Motivation dazu,
irgendwas zu machen, vorher nicht.
Ja, Matt, Vision Studios echt nice.
So, ich hab's geschafft,
ich bin nur mal unten am Chat, ich hab alles durchgelesen.
Okay, ähm, wie filtern wir
das Ganze? Na jetzt, mal was machen hier.
Dass die Suche funktioniert.
Okay, wir filtern
das mit, ähm...
Wenn Item
Name
Lowercase
Ich hoffe,
das hieß so in JavaScript, too lowercase, ne?
Too lowercase
Was zum Teufel ist too local lowercase?
Okay, in JavaScript ist lowercase
nicht lowercase, sondern
von dem Standort abhängig
oder so, vom, okay.
Versteh ich zwar nicht, aber
ähm,
wie kann man das schön machen?
...
Das ist ein ziemlich hässliches
ziemlich hässlicher
hässliches if.
Aber es sollte funktionieren.
Okay, also von der Idee her sollten wir jetzt
rausfiltern.
Gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
Nein, funktioniert nicht.
Ah.
Okay, warte mal, wir machen noch was anderes.
Im Moment habe
das HTML überhaupt angepasst?
Natürlich nicht. Na geil.
Kein Wunder, wahrscheinlich hätte es jetzt auch funktioniert.
Ha.
Oder auch nicht.
Eigentlich will ich jetzt ja nur,
dass der Input gefiltert wird.
Also bzw. die Bildchen
anhand dessen, was ich eintippe.
Das brennt sich doch von der Idee her
recht logisch aus, oder?
Wir filtern
die Items, je nachdem
ob der Name
den Filter enthält
oder ob
Text
den Filter enthält.
Den Filter enthält.
Machen wir den Filter
auch mal klein, dann sieht es schon ein bisschen ordentlicher
wieder aus.
Ich habe mich bestimmt irgendwo verschrieben.
Gucken wir mal, was
der Browser ausgibt.
Ah, jetzt geht's.
Lol.
Geht's.
Funktioniert.
Komm, er durchsucht auch
den Text.
Das ist doch nice.
Und man sieht auch mal,
wie responsive das hier ist.
Also sprich, so könnte man es auf dem Handy verwenden.
Von der Größe her.
Ungefähr.
Sagen wir mal so.
Könnte man es auf dem Handy verwenden.
Oder auf Desktop, auf dem Tablet.
Wo ist hier Raku hin?
Die haben wir noch nicht eingebaut.
Von der haben wir leider nur immer noch
noch ein MonkaS.
Das kommt als nächstes.
Als nächstes bauen wir hier Raku ein.
Ja, jetzt tut die Suche auch.
So, jetzt haben wir im Prinzip
bis auf die
Vorschaureihen für OBS
alles so drinne, wie wir es
in der ersten Version
vom Meme-Tool drinne hatten.
Bloß, dass wir jetzt besser sind
und mehr machen können.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Aber jetzt sind wir wieder besser.
Jetzt können wir was einbauen.
Und mehr machen können.
Das heißt, jetzt können wir anfangen
neues Zeug einzubauen.
Soetwas wie ordentliches Text-to-Speech
mit Weeb-Engine und sowas.
Aber dann bin ich heute zu kaputt für
mir da noch tiefgreifende Gedanken
zu machen, wie wir das einbauen.
Das werden wir im Prinzip
Im Prinzip basteln wir uns für jede Text-to-Speech-Engine, die wir verwenden, basteln wir uns irgendwie eine eigene Klasse.
Und je nachdem, was man für eine Sprache ausgewählt hat im Webinterface, nimmt ihr halt das zum Abspielen.
Wir können mal gucken, das letzte Mal haben wir doch hier für diese japanische Text-to-Speech-Engine, haben wir doch das letzte Mal was gebaut schon.
Das ist doch Test für die japanische Text-to-Speech-Engine hier.
Ja, richtig, das ist das doch. Gucken wir mal.
Ja, sag mir mal nen Text. Alter, oh, nie so was.
Sag mir mal nen Text für die japanische Text-to-Speech-Engine, was könnte man da nehmen?
Wir brauchen jetzt mal was, was ich gut für ne japanische Text-to-Speech-Engine eignet.
Wieso heißt du eigentlich Wupploh auf Twitch?
Weil der Account ursprünglich gar nicht so auf Stream gedacht war.
Und weil ich mir dann gedacht habe, es ist gar nicht so schlecht, wenn man mich nicht direkt mit YouTube in Verbindung bringt,
weil dann plus die gescheiten Leute kommen.
Wie funktioniert das, dass die Bilder groß angezeigt werden? Ist das dann quasi ein Overlay?
Du meinst, dass die Bilder überhaupt angezeigt werden, ne? Also quasi.
Äh, ups, vielleicht sollte ich auch ins richtige Programm gehen.
Also quasi, ne, dass wenn ich jetzt hier im Browser bin und hier Overlay mache, du meinst sowas hier, ne?
Dass man hier durchklicken kann und dass es das nicht beeinflusst.
Ja, damit das funktioniert, das ist der ein bisschen trickreichere Part, besteht die Anwendung eher aus zwei verschiedenen Projekten.
Es gibt einmal das Web-Interface und es gibt eine WPF-Desktop-Anwendung.
Die WPF-Desktop-Anwendung ist relativ simpel. Das ist einfach ein transparentes Fenster.
Das ist ein transparentes Fenster mit einem einzelnen Image-Element drin, wo man was anzeigen kann. Mehr nicht.
So, und da ist eingestellt, dass das Fenster immer im Vordergrund ist, dass es standardmäßig 1000 Pixel hoch, 1000 Pixel breit ist,
dass es in der Task-Leist übrigens nicht angezeigt werden sollte und dass auch der Hintergrund transparent ist.
Dass Windows-Teile, dass keine Knöpfe und so angezeigt werden.
Ja, im Prinzip ist es ein Fenster, was du nicht siehst, wo die Bilder drin angezeigt werden.
So, und da drinnen habe ich dann halt ein bisschen Logik zum Anzeigen von Bildchen.
Und das wird von der Web-Anwendung letztendlich einfach nur aufgerufen.
Und achso, und wie ist es dann durchklickbar? Okay, jetzt wird es wirklich trickreich. Jetzt wird es wirklich trickreich.
Also durchklickbar ist deswegen zwei Sachen erst mal.
Und zwar, ich muss mal kurz gucken, wo ich das jetzt hier hingeschrieben habe.
Genau, also so verhalten, wegen ein paar Sachen. Einmal, ich muss mal kurz die Nase putzen.
So, das funktioniert wegen ein paar Sachen. Einmal, dass du es nicht siehst, liegt daran, dass der Hintergrund alles transparent ist.
Und das mit dem Durchklicken, das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen, also es sind ja zwei Sachen. Ich starte das noch mal.
Es sind ja zwei Sachen, die dazugehören. Es ist einmal das Durchklicken, was funktioniert.
Und das nächste ist, dass es, ihr seht, kein Fokus wegnimmt.
Also ihr seht im Hintergrund, ich markiere hier weiter, obwohl das Bild auf und ab ploppt. Also das hat keine Auswirkungen drauf auf den Rest.
So, und das sind zwei Sachen. Dass es den Fokus nicht wegnimmt, liegt einmal daran, dass es im Vordergrund ist, immer.
Und dass ich, bevor ich das Fenster verstecke und wieder anzeigen lasse, Show Activated auf False setze.
Dann crappt sich das Fenster beim Aufgehen keinen Fokus.
Das ist in WPF mit drinnen, dazu braucht man keine extra Wurst.
Das klappt so. Und das Durchklicken ist tatsächlich ein bisschen komplizierter.
Das Durchklicken ist ein bisschen komplizierter und das passiert hier.
Dass das funktioniert, muss man leider ein bisschen native Windows interne Funktionen aufrufen.
Man kann hier quasi eine Methode überschreiben von WPF, die automatisch aufgerufen wird, wenn das Fenster gestartet wird.
Und da drinnen rufe ich hier dieses Set WindowXTransparent auf mit dem Handle von meinem Fenster.
Das ist Windows internes Geschwubbel, das muss man halt so machen.
So, und Set WindowXTransparent ist diese Klasse hier.
Unter der Haube macht er im Endeffekt das hier.
Fragt mich nicht, was es macht, weil ich habe es hier von Stack Overflow kopiert.
Ich habe es versucht zu checken, das ist schon ein paar Streams her, da haben wir versucht zusammen rauszukriegen, was es eigentlich genau tut.
Wir haben es nicht verstanden, aber es tut.
Das ist halt typisch Windows interne Funktionen.
Da hat man oft mal so ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten.
Die Dokumentation von Microsoft ist in der Regel ziemlich gut, allerdings das hat sich mir nicht so ganz erschlossen.
Es setzt irgendwelche speziellen Flacks für das Fenster, dass es eben click through ist.
Es funktioniert.
Aber was es genau tut unter der Haube, keine Ahnung.
Und wie funktioniert das trotz Fullscreen Anwendung?
Ja, weil das funktioniert, weil das Fenster topmost ist, weil das Fenster immer im Vordergrund ist.
So, und wenn es eine richtige Fullscreen Anwendung ist, dann klappt es auch nicht.
Also wenn es eine exklusiv Fullscreen Anwendung ist, die quasi übertrieben sich den Monitor Output gekrappt hat, dann geht das nicht.
Da kann man auch nichts machen, außer sich irgendwie, so wie das Flaps macht oder so, mit dem FPS-Counter da in irgendwelche Diode-X-Aufrufe reinhängen.
Aber dann hast du wieder das Problem, dass wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Cheat-Engines auch anschlagen und denken, du bescheißt, weil sich da was reinhängt.
Dann funktioniert das nicht, aber es haben ja alle Games sowas wie Borderless-Window-Mode.
Und es ist ja mittlerweile auch Standard, dass die meisten Games überhaupt nicht mehr exklusiv Fullscreen starten.
Allein schon, weil das Raustappen dann 5 Sekunden dauert und der Monitor bei rumspackt.
Sondern die Spiele laufen heute ja standardmäßig zu 99% in Borderless-Fullscreen-Window, also im Fullscreen-Window-Mode.
Halt in einem Window, im Fullscreen, allerdings ohne Render.
So, und halt nicht exklusiv Fullscreen. Deswegen funktioniert das heute bei allen Games.
Und die meisten älteren Games, die kann man auch in Borderless-Window-Modus versetzen.
Also, dann funktioniert das.
Weil man jetzt hier irgendwie, was haben wir denn, was können wir denn mal anmachen?
Wie stellt man den Scheiß hier überhaupt wieder um?
Wenn man das World of Goo auf, und sobald das Spiel halt im Window-Fullscreen läuft, was ich mal hoffe, dass es macht, dann kann ich hier natürlich auch Sachen anzeigen.
Das Game spackt rum.
Okay, das setze ich jetzt drauf. In dem Game funktioniert es jetzt nicht, weil es irgendwie meine Tastatureingaben crappt.
Achso, ich hab das Programm gar nicht laufen. Äh, vergiss es.
Lull.
Es sei denn, das ist exklusiv Fullscreen, dann funktioniert das nicht.
Das scheint mir echt exklusiv Fullscreen zu sein.
Das habe ich in den letzten Streams gesehen, also in Black Ops funktioniert es, in so ziemlich allem funktioniert es eigentlich.
Was meine Tastatureingaben nicht crappt.
Und wenn die Tastatureingaben gekrappt werden, kann ich immer noch über den zweiten Bildschirm aufmachen.
Und bei älteren Games wie dem hier, wo Fullscreen ist, dann muss man halt gucken in den Settings, wie man das am besten rauskriegt.
Aber guckt, selbst hier funktioniert es.
Das ist ein altes Source-Game, was eigentlich gar nicht so richtig das mag, wenn man da Bilder anzeigt, wie man jetzt hier auch sieht, weil es rausgeht.
Da muss man halt den Window-Modus stellen. Wenn man den Window-Modus stellt, dann funktioniert es.
Ja.
Also im Prinzip, bisschen so, was Elgato Stream Deck auch macht, bloß ohne Elgato Stream Deck.
Und mit mehr Funktionen letztendlich, die man, also was heißt mehr Funktionen, mit anderen Funktionen, die man sich auch selbst einbauen kann.
Wo man halt machen kann, was man will.
Wichtig ist jetzt einfach nur, dass die Anwendung Fullscreen-Windows läuft. Dann funktioniert sie auch.
Und keine Tastatureingaben weggekrappt. Aber das machen die wenigsten Programme heutzutage, weil es ja auch letztendlich den User abfuckt.
Ja.
Als nächstes bauen wir dann die Text-to-Speech, die japanische Text-to-Speech-Geschichte ein.
Ich meine, guck, es ist Fullscreen-Video hier jetzt.
Zwar stellvertretend für, weil ich keine Gamescast wirklich installiert hab.
Überhaupt kein Ding.
Es muss halt nur Fullscreen-Windows-Modus laufen.
Dann funktioniert das.
Okay, wir brauchen noch einen Text für unsere japanische Text-to-Speech-Engine.
Das haben wir das letzte Mal schon ausprobiert. Das hat nicht funktioniert, oder? Omega 0 konnten die nicht gut aussprechen.
Er hat es nicht funktioniert.
Mein zweiter Rechner ist gerade abgekackt. Und die Soundkarte macht einen ganz eklichen Pieps-Ton.
Aber das Schöne ist, ich streame ja von dem Rechner aus, das heißt, da passiert nichts.
Das heißt, ich bin immer noch live, aber ich sehe den Chat nicht mehr.
Ich sehe den Chat jetzt nur noch in meiner Stream-Vorschau.
Ich muss nämlich den zweiten Rechner wieder anmachen.
Während der Rechner hochfährt, mache ich hier mal an.
Na, jetzt mal neu starten.
Null. Geht der Chat hier gerade, oder spackt das rum?
Was hältst du bislang von den neuen Intels?
Ich habe mich da nur am Rande angeguckt. Ich weiß nur, dass sie irgendwie ihre Benchmarks gegenüber AMD sehr schön gerechnet haben.
Was ich ja schon wieder affig finde.
Zaukst du noch Battlefield 4? Nee, habe ich gar nicht mehr installiert.
Habe ich nicht mehr installiert.
Genau, wir wollen jetzt mal gucken, ob wir ein paar nächste Textospeech...
OMEGALOL ging, glaube ich, nicht. Das war ein bisschen fail.
Nein, OMEGALOL kann ich nicht gut aussprechen.
Nope, das funktioniert nicht.
Aber letztendlich ist es ja dem User auch selbst überlassen, was er für einen Text eingibt und welch Text-to-Speech-Engine er verwendet.
Wir bieten standardmäßig mal an, Windows Default und Weep Text-to-Speech.
So, mein zweiter Rechner ist wieder da.
Komm, wir brauchen nochmal einen ordentlichen Text. Irgendwas, was die wahrscheinlich auch gut aussprechen kann.
Kann mein zweiter Rechner jetzt mal ordentlich hochfahren?
Blitz!
Skype. Alter, es startet sich Skype. Skype habe ich seit 5 Monaten immer angehabt oder so.
Skype in 2K18. Wer will denn Skype haben?
Lol.
Ok, mein zweiter Rechner ist wieder am Start. Alles gut.
Ja, gibt es noch irgendwelche Sachen, die wir besprechen müssen? Können? Immer?
Weil es ist jetzt schon relativ spät und für irgendwelche Sachen, wo ich mich großartig konzentrieren muss, habe ich gerade keinen Kopf mehr.
Also irgendwelche großartige, tolle Logik programmieren kriege ich nicht mal gebacken.
Wir werden mal versuchen, dass wir in einem der nächsten Programmier-Streams bauen wir dann die japanische Text-to-Speech-Geschichte noch ein.
Und dann bauen wir ein Paket draus, was jeder mal ausprobieren kann.
Und ich denke, ich weiß ja nicht, ob ich ein Video mache, so ein Vorstellungsvideo auf YouTube für das Tool.
Weil ich könnte mir vorstellen, das ist etwas, was vielen Streamern was bringt.
Ja, da kannst du auch lustige Sachen mit machen. Ich meine, wir können noch Animationen einbauen für die Memes.
Wir können noch verschiedene Text-to-Speech-Engines einbauen oder irgendwie alles mögliche.
Ich habe eine riesen Feature-Liste, was man noch alles machen könnte.
Was wir auch noch machen müssten, den Sortierknopf.
Das hat übrigens mittlerweile Error-Handling. Wenn ich einen Shortcut vergebe, den ich schon habe, dann geht es nicht.
Krass, oder?
Sobald ich einen vergebe, den es noch nicht gibt, funktioniert es.
So, wann und wie kann ich Lambda benutzen in C-Sharp?
Wann? Immer wenn du eine Action als Parameter hast.
Warte mal, meine Tastatur geht gerade nicht.
Okay, was auch immer.
Ja, immer wenn du eine Action hast als Parameter. Zum Beispiel, wenn du...
Nehmen wir mal hier die andere, die Konsolenanwendung.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du...
Wenn du eine Liste aus Zahlen hast.
So was hier. Und du willst die filtern.
Und wenn du mal guckst, wer möchte eine Action oder Funktion haben.
Und an der Stelle kannst du immer Lambda verwenden.
Also du kannst prinzipiell an den Stellen, wo du Funktionen übergeben würdest, normalerweise kannst du Lambda anstelle verwenden.
Im Prinzip ist ja das quasi eine Inline-Funktion, wenn du das so willst.
Also du könntest jetzt entweder hier die Funktion reinschreiben, die du aufrufen willst, oder du schreibst die halt direkt hier an der Stelle.
Und dann kannst du jetzt quasi sagen, für jede Zahl in diesem Array willst du es filtern, ob die Zahl größer als 5 ist.
So. Und das hier ist im Prinzip dein Lambda. Das ist die Funktion, die du aufrufst.
Jedes Element nennt es halt i. Und das hier ist die eigentliche Funktion, i größer als 5.
Ausgeschrieben würde das Ganze so aussehen.
Aber ein Zeiler kann man abkürzen.
Das ist quasi sowas wie eine Inline-Funktion. Du schreibst das quasi an Ort und Stelle, anstatt woanders und gibst hier den Namen an.
Was halt bei sowas wie hier unglaublich praktisch ist, weil ich mein, alternativ müsstest du da halt eine Funktion machen, die sich keine Ahnung...
Ah, ich hab das Makropaket nicht installiert, die sich dann halt Filter nennt oder sowas.
Filter. Und dann müsstest du dann quasi hier drin angeben, du willst Filter verwenden.
So ist das viel schöner.
Und damit kann man ganz abgedrehte Sachen machen. Ach ja, übrigens, für Events geht das Ganze auch.
Also wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel, gehen wir mal in unsere WPF-Anwendung.
Wenn wir da nen Event drinne haben, zum Beispiel Loaded.
Loaded ist ein Event, das wird gefeuert, wenn das Ding angezeigt wird, oder? Ja, wenn die Form das erste Mal gerendert wird.
Ähm, normalerweise muss man es in C-Sharp ja so machen.
Äh, bis denn, AX. Normalerweise sieht es ja so aus, bei nem Event, man...
Hallo, Wüschel Studio, please.
Mag das nicht mehr?
Normalerweise hat es das immer automatisch gemacht. Cool.
Ähm, tja.
Äh, normalerweise muss man jetzt hier hinten quasi ne Funktion angeben, ach jetzt.
Ähm, ne Funktion angeben, die er aufruft.
Also wenn das Event auftritt, ruft er die Funktion MainWindowLoaded auf und dann brauchen wir das hier als Funktion.
Und das geht natürlich mit nem Lambda auch viel schöner.
Dann sagst du hier einfach, ok, ähm, als Parameter krieg ich in dem Fall von diesem Event krieg ich dir das, was es ausgelöst hat und Event AX.
Und mache dann damit folgendes. Fertig.
Für Sachen kurz und knackig ist es natürlich viel schöner so.
Ich hab über Nacht für die Uni ein Java-Programm geschrieben, was ich als Test abgeben muss.
Nice.
Und was ging's denn da?
Über Nacht. Das kann ja nicht alles so großes sein, oder?
Über Nacht finde ich immer problematisch, weil ähm, gute Ideen, vor allem halt auch für logische Abläufe, die müssen auch oft mal so ein bisschen reifen, ja.
Also es geht mir ganz oft so, dass ich die erste Version von irgendwas zusammenwurste und mir danach einfällt, so schön war das gar nicht.
Wie jetzt zum Beispiel hier mit dem Tool, ja.
Die neue Version, die wir hier haben, die ist so viel sauberer und so viel schöner und so viel einfacher auch dann was zu machen, ähm,
dass ich im Prinzip ja gelohnt hat, dass wir es vorher mal dirty gemacht haben.
Einfach, dass man dann auf Ideen gekommen ist, wie man es anders machen könnte.
Es braucht immer ein bisschen, ja. Manchmal braucht man noch zwei, drei Anläufe, bis es dann richtig funktioniert.
Deswegen ist es immer schwierig, was zu basteln über Nacht, wenn man es morgen abgeben muss.
Weil da hat man halt einfach die Zeit nicht, ne.
Gute Ideen kriegt man im Scheißhaus, ja, das stimmt, ja.
Ja, also es gibt so ein paar Orte.
Äh, auf dem Klo oder in der Dusche.
Ähm, teilweise vom Fernsehen, wobei ich gucke halt sehr wenig Fernsehen.
Aber wenn ich draußen mit der Katze irgendwo hocke, ja, also, so die richtig guten Ansätze, wie man was machen könnte,
fallen einem meistens nicht vor dem PC ein und sitzen.
Deswegen sieht man mal wieder, wie wichtig das ist, dass, ähm, und ich weiß, dass es halt an vielen Stellen nicht so ist.
Wie wichtig das ist, dass, ähm, wenn man was Kreatives machen soll, was ja Programmier noch ist,
dass man da einen angenehmen, ruhigen Arbeitsplatz hat, um sowas zu machen.
Weil eins ist, ist, ja, fucked.
Ähm, unter Stress kann man nicht kreativ sein.
Das sehen viele Leute anders, aber das ist ja rein evolutionstechnisch bedingt schon Absicht.
Ja, also, wenn ich quasi unter Druck bin, Stress habe, irgendwie Adrenalin im Blut habe,
dann kann ich jetzt super jemand anderem auf die Fresse hauen.
Aber, ähm, Bilder malen nicht unbedingt, Programmieren auch nicht unbedingt, Musik machen auch nicht unbedingt
und kreative Ideen habe ich dann auch nicht.
Da kann ich schnell rennen, da kann ich andere Leute umhauen, da kann ich aggressive Sachen machen,
äh, flüchten oder sonst was, aber unter Stress kann man keine kreativen Sachen machen.
Deswegen hilft es auch überhaupt nicht, wenn irgendjemand möchte von euch was haben
und er geht euch auf den Sack.
Dann funktioniert das nicht.
Das hat noch nie funktioniert, noch nie irgendwo.
Weil das komplett gegen die, ja, so gegen die Natur im Endeffekt ist,
unter Stress kreative Sachen, man geht einfach nicht.
Ja, im Zug, genau, im Zug habe ich auch viele Ideen oft.
Wie Hardwarener ist eigentlich so eine Instanz vom TCP-Client?
Ich vermute mal nicht allzu Hardwarener, die werden irgendwelche Windows-APs rappen dafür.
Das ist bestimmt nichts, was selbst irgendwelche Pakete zusammenbaut
oder sich um Sachen unten drunter kümmert.
Das ist bestimmt nur ein Rapper für irgendwelche Windows-Funktionen.
Also wahrscheinlich nicht allzu Hardwarener.
Aber das Schöne ist ja mittlerweile ist.NET Open Source auf GitHub.
Kannst du es einfach angucken.
Das ist der Source-Code von TCP-Client vom Offiziellen.
Easy.
593 Zeilen lang und sieht für mich jetzt, okay, kein Rapper für Windows-Funktionen,
Rapper für die Socket-Library ist ja auch irgendwo klar, wenn man darüber nachdenkt.
Die.NET Socket-Library wird wahrscheinlich auch eher auf Windows-Funktionen beruhen,
anstatt dass sie das selbst machen.
Also nicht sonderlich Hardwarener, um nicht zu sagen gar nicht Hardwarener.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Der.NET TCP-Client ist bloß 493 Zeilen lang.
Ach so.
Abgaben sieben Tage, das ist ja kein Ding.
Morgen fällt mir gerade eine.
Morgen ist in Hessen Wahl und ich habe keine Ahnung, wen ich wählen soll.
Ich gehe zwar immer wählen, aber ich habe keine Ahnung, wen ich wählen soll.
Was dann meistens darauf rausläuft, dass ich dann irgendwas blödes Zeug auf dem Zettel
klatsche und den abgebe.
Also im Prinzip ist es ungültig danach.
Willst du dir das kleine Programm mal anschauen?
Ja, was macht es denn?
Was macht es denn?
Frankfurt ist in Hessen.
Das am Main schon.
Ich mache immer ansonsten den hier.
Den Walomat mache ich immer.
Aber da habe ich jetzt 40 Fragen, kein Bock.
Wählen Piraten, die wollen was mit Computer.
Ja, die haben es die letzten Jahre so verschissen.
Die hatten eigentlich immer einen ganz guten Start, aber ja.
Die Plakate sind ziemlich cringy.
Am cringiesten letzten Zeit war tatsächlich Gaming Strom.
Bei uns hängt so ein Typ hier um die Ecke, wo ich keine Ahnung habe, was das Plakat mir sagen soll.
Das ist so ein Viereck um den Kopf von dem Typ und nochmal ein Viereck um seine Hand,
wo ich mir so denke, wollen die uns sagen, dass ihr Kandidat Hände hat oder was?
Oh, Datum, Date, Time, das ist ein ganz, ganz fieses Thema.
Also Programme, die mit Datum und Uhrzeit hantieren, die sehen bloß auf den ersten Blick einfach aus.
Und das ist meistens immer ganz, ganz schlimm.
Aber wenn du willst, kannst du es irgendwo mal hochladen, also auf Codeshare oder so.
Oder auf Pastebin oder such dir irgendeine Seite aus, wo man den Source Code hinkopieren kann.
Da können wir es uns, wenn du willst, mal am Stream angucken.
Ich meine, ich kann nicht großartig Java programmieren, aber ich kann es lesen.
Gamingstrom, ja, tatsächlich.
Was fällt dir spontan ein, um in einem Array nach Duplikaten zu suchen?
Vergleichsbasierte Suchen oder vielleicht Tricky mit einem Dictionary oder so?
Mache gerade was mit Unity.
Es kommt drauf an, was du haben willst.
Ich mache mal kurz eine neue Konsolenanwendung.
Also das Einfachste, um in einem Array nach Duplikaten zu suchen, ist tatsächlich das hier.
Das ist eingebaut.
Moment, wir sind nicht scharf, wir sind nicht in JavaScript.
Ich bin gerade verwirrt.
List.
Also das ist das Einfachste.
Wobei das halt...
Das war doch doppelt, oder?
Oder waren das die Einzelnen?
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, nicht dass ich jetzt Mist erzähle.
Doch, oder?
Das sind doch die Doppelten.
Können wir doch gleich mal ausprobieren, ob das die Doppelten sind.
Machen wir einfach mal int 11234.
Hups, ich kann nicht schreiben.
Ah, okay.
Haha.
Nee, nee.
Man bekommt...
Ah, nee, nee, okay.
Dann funktioniert das so nicht.
Du bekommst nicht die Doppelten wieder, du bekommst von jedem eins wieder und die Doppelten nicht.
Also das ist quasi den Unic oder sowas.
Ach so, ah, so war das, genau.
Das entfernt quasi die Doppelten.
Mit einem Hashset könntest du es machen, mit einem Hashset.
Das Problem ist, wenn du jetzt quasi das Array erst in ein Dictionary packst oder in ein Set,
das dauert halt, je nachdem wie groß das Array ist.
Das dauert halt vielleicht länger als einfach sinnlos durchsuchen.
Also du willst quasi wissen, du willst quasi die Doppelten Elemente haben, ne?
Ach, nies.
Wie könnte man das schön machen?
Mit Link könnte man bestimmt irgendwas schönes basteln.
So, was wirklich richtig schön kurz und knackig ist, außer mit Link?
Ich hab ne Idee.
Also mit Link könnte man, könnte man das gruppen.
Du könntest, mit Link könntest du sagen, quasi die gleichen Elemente kopieren
und dann ausgeben.
Das müsste wahrscheinlich funktionieren, aber ich weiß nicht, wie schnell das ist.
Also mit Link würde mir sowas hier einfallen, dass man sowas macht.
Mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Würden wir sowas hier irgendwie, dass man sagt.
Grup.
Jetzt muss ich nur mal überlegen, was der für ein...
Was weiß ich hier irgendwie.
Sowas hier.
Mal gucken, ob das prinzipiell funktioniert.
Achso, äh.
Das sind jetzt ja einzelne.
Ähm, das würde funktionieren.
Ne.
Ach, Moment.
Schwachsinn.
falscher Stelle.
Ja, das würde funktionieren.
Guck, jetzt hast du die Dinger schön gegrubt.
Aber ich weiß ja nicht, wie schnell das ist mit größeren Arrays.
Äh, wenn du die löschen willst, das geht doch mit Distinct.
Das ist doch genau das, was du haben willst.
Distinct macht quasi Unique aus dem Array.
Also schmeißt quasi alles Doppelte raus.
Aber so kriegste...
Aber so kriegste kopiert.
Da weißt du, du hast zwei mal eins.
Einmal zwei, einmal drei, einmal vier.
Aber ich glaube, das ist nicht sonderlich effizient, was der Link intern macht.
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
Vor allem, wenn das Array relativ groß ist.
Äh, gut.
1.100 Elemente ist jetzt nicht so krass viel.
Ähm, Paste Bin.
Also, das hier, das finde ich vom Ansatz her eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht.
1.100.
Ja, das ist sonderlich.
Das geht schon.
Raffi, das ist das ja nicht.
So, also hier, jetzt hast du ja die einzelnen Dinge kopiert.
Was genau willst du damit jetzt machen?
Ja gut, dann wird das Ding nicht funktionieren, weil die Elemente ja nicht gleich sind.
Da müsste man, also, das ist ja nicht die gleiche Referenz, ja.
Könntest du nicht, jetzt war eine ganz, ganz blöde Idee.
Könntest du nicht wirklich sagen, ähm, ups.
Genau, das war nämlich gerade.
Kann man dem Ding nicht sagen?
Doch, man kann das, doch, dann geht das Ganze doch.
Dann kannst du dir sagen, wenn im Angenommen, du hast jetzt hier irgendwie einen, ja, irgendwie
class, irgendwie my class und da drin hast du dann halt deine, dein int, all die oder
irgendwie sowas.
Ähm, und davon hast du jetzt eine Liste.
Das ist im Prinzip ja das, wo du dann quasi 6100 hast.
So, und dann könntest du eigentlich hier drinnen sagen, weil wenn man, wenn man hier
einen, wenn man hier einen Lambda übergeben kann zum Compa, äh, kann man, Moment, kann
man einen Lambda zum Compa übergeben?
Nee, kann man nicht.
Oder, kann man doch?
Kann man?
Aber, steht jetzt zumindest nicht da, dass man, dass, dass, dass, dass man kann.
Nee, kann man nicht.
Kann man nicht.
Nee, ja, ja, das müsste so gehen, aber Distinct äh, mag keine, mag keinen Lambdas haben.
Da müsste man wahrscheinlich eine eigene Extension-Message basteln oder so.
Mal guck, du hast hier plus zur Auswahl, entweder nichts oder halt einen eigenen Comparer und
keine, so, aber das kannst du machen, du kannst natürlich, ähm, wenn das einfachste
wäre, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du es einfach überschreibst, ne, wenn irgendwie, wenn du
Equals überschreibst oder sowas, falls man, falls man das will, normalerweise will man
das eigentlich nicht.
Oder du machst einen eigenen Comparer, das müsste eigentlich funktionieren, ja.
Das dürfte eigentlich am einfachsten sein, machst einen eigenen Comparer, weil da kannst,
da brauchst du hier nichts mehr drin, da kannst du einfach sehen, Distinct und gut ist.
Das klingt mir jetzt auf den ersten Blick eigentlich am sinnigsten.
Ja, brauchst du nicht, oder?
Kann man nicht, kann man nicht irgendwie einen Comparer basteln, also man muss ja, man muss
ja nicht in Klasse, oder?
Man kann, ich weiß es aus dem Kopf ehrlich gesagt nicht, ja, aber du brauchst doch nicht
den Zugriff auf die Klasse, man, man, so, so ein Comparer ist doch eine eigene Klasse,
oder?
Also man kann zwar Equals überschreiben, aber das will man ja in der Regel gar nicht.
Das macht nicht so selten, sowas.
Einen Comparer kann man machen und den kannst du da eigentlich an Distinct übergeben, das
müsste doch eigentlich funktionieren.
Aber ich finde es ein bisschen merkwürdig, dass man keine, eine Equal überschreiben kann
sie nicht, das stimmt.
Aber ich finde es ein bisschen komisch, dass das nicht geht.
Ja, im Prinzip machen ist jetzt jeder auch so.
Moin, no need to fake.
Ja, ähm, wo habe ich denn jetzt den Code?
Ähm, habe ich den Coding gepastet von Moon Eater?
Ja.
Woop, woop, woop, woop, woop.
So, also, was macht es?
Simple class for checking dates in year under consideration of leap year.
Oh, das ist so eklig.
Das ist wirklich eklig.
Zeit und, und Date-Time-Vergleiche, es ist, das von Hand zu machen, aber ich meine es
ist ja zu üben, ja.
Also ich, aber nur mal so generell gesagt, ich würde nie, nie Date-Time und Zeitsachen
selbst machen.
Aber in dem Fall ist es wahrscheinlich die Aufgabe, du musst.
Oh, moin, eiskäuter.
So, ähm, int day, var gibt es nicht in Java, ne, finde ich mittlerweile echt praktisch.
Int pass int, was machst du, wenn als AK man etwas eingibt, das man nicht passen kann
als int.
Das ist immer so das erste, was ich mache für sowas.
Und wisst ihr auch schon alles brav, was ihr morgen wählt?
Ne.
Wir können ja den Valomart zusammen mal machen.
Wollen wir den Valomart machen?
Ähm, okay, wenn das, wenn das Jahr kleiner ist wie 1900, okay, check, ja, das ist halt
halt die, die, ähm, die ekliche Sache am Berechnen.
Gibt's ja da auch, die, die Regeln sind ja in der Regel, also die Regeln waren in Schaltehörsen
und so.
Das ist auf den ersten Blick immer ganz einfach, aber bei Daytime-Geschichten und Zeiten und
Zeitzonen, da steckt so der Teufel im Detail.
Was, ernsthaft, sollen wir wirklich den Valomart machen?
Na gut, wenn ihr euch das interessiert, können wir den Valomart machen, äh, aber vorher,
gucken wir mal das hier nochmal fertig an, so, check all, ne, switch mal, äh, das sieht
ganz ordentlich aus, ja, wenn der Monat größer als 12 ist oder kleiner als 1 ist, also sprich,
wenn jemand Mist eingegeben hat, aber es sich, aber, aber sich der Mist als Int parsen lässt,
hat, hat Java sowas wie TriPass, dann würde ich das verwenden, also quasi versuche zu
pasen, wenn nicht, dann lassen wir es halt sein, ich weiß schon wahrscheinlich, also
ich weiß wahrscheinlich was ich morgen wähle, ja, aber wahrscheinlich wähle ich wieder,
so dass, dass es nicht zählt, die Eindrückung hier ist ein bisschen komisch, ähm, wat, ah,
du willst abfangen, dass der Februar nur, nur 28 Tage hat, ne, oh, Daytime-Sachen vorhand
ist wirklich eklig, ah, wenn Schaltjahr dann, wo ist denn Schaltjahr gesetzt, ah, hier,
also das, da würde ich, da würde ich, da würde ich auf jeden Fall irgendwie ein bisschen
Funktionen draus machen, so man, du machst hier den Check im Endeffekt hier 20 mal oder
so, na 20 mal nicht, 9 mal, na gut, dann im Prinzip immer wieder das gleiche, äh, what
day, also ich finde, es sieht zumindest recht ordentlich aus, nur halt das Daytime-Sachen
vorhanden, du, du sollst das selbst machen, ne, du kannst nicht einfach irgendwie, äh,
Daytime-Standard-Library verwenden, oder, das wird's nämlich deutlich vereinfachen,
day gleich day plus 31, was macht das ganze hier jetzt, warum, warum machst du day gleich
day plus 31, day plus 59, der, hä, das wirkt mir irgendwie ziemlich doppelt, für was
ist das da, Schaltjahr muss ein Tag mehr drauf wegen, 29.
Februar, ne, ne, ich mein, wofür, das ganze da, also plus 31 plus 29, ach, du willst ausrechnen,
was es für ein Tag im Jahr ist, na, ach so, ah, das, das würde ich ein bisschen anders
machen, das würde ich anders machen, also, das erste, was man einfällt, das erste, was
mir einfällt, ist, ne Dictionary zu machen, mit, ähm, ja, war ja so ähnlich aus, ne Dictionary
zu, alter, kann das jetzt mal ordentlich schreiben, ja, ne, ich geh in die andere Anwendung rein,
ich würd mir ne Dictionary machen, erste Mal, aber im Februar muss man halt ein bisschen
gucken, da musste, da musste eh rechnen, ja, also ich würd mir irgendwie erstmal ne Dictionary
machen, mit, ähm, das Visual Studio mag gerade nicht, so was in der Richtung, wie
keine Ahnung, String, Int, und dann steht da so was drinne, wie, Januar 31, ähm, ich
mein, beim Februar hast du eh gelitten, ja, beim Februar nimmst du halt 28 und 29, ist
ja egal, musst dann eh gucken, ob der Schalter jetzt in der Landwirtschaft rechnen, aber
dadurch hast du den Vorteil, du brauchst diesen ganzen, diesen ganzen Schwubbel hier
nicht, du sagst dann nämlich einfach, ähm, also du holst dir das einfach dann einmalig
aus dem Dictionary raus, und dann musst du nicht jedes Mal selbst rechnen, du könntest
auch als Key den, den, ähm, als Key den, den, den Monat, den Monat nehmen, ja, also
dass du hier nicht sagst, Name als Key, sondern, sondern den, den Monat als Key, so, und wenn
du das so machst, wenn du das so machst, kannst du dann quasi hier drinne schreiben,
ähm, ohne, dass du den ganzen, das ganze Gedöns hier brauchst überhaupt, kannst du
dann schreiben, einmalig, day gleich, Dictionary, month, und dann hast du es eigentlich, dann
musst du nur noch gucken, ähm, ob es ein Schalter ist, und dann machst du in Februar
eins drauf, und dann machst du einmal die Textausgabe, also im Prinzip hast du dann
anstatt eine Funktion mit irgendwie zu 100 Zeilen, oder mit, mit 150 Zeilen, hast du
dann 4 Zeilen, achso ihr sollt, ihr sollt viele Ifs machen, ok, dann, dann, dann ist
natürlich das voll und ganz erfüllt, viele Ifs, ok, also, machen wir jetzt den Wahlomat,
im Schnelldurchlauf, Wahlomat Hessen, also was soll ich morgen wählen, mal gucken was
daraus kommt, mir übrigens, mir helfen solche Sachen in der Regel nicht, weil ich hab dann
irgendwie 50 davon, 50 davon, 50 davon, und alle sind komplett aus der anderen Richtung,
ja, ok, ähm, also, das ist die erste Frage, das Nachtflugverbot am Frankfurter Flughafen
soll ausgeweitet werden, ähm, naja, also nachdem ich gerne überall in der Welt hinkommen
möchte, und auch will, dass in Frankfurt quasi verkehrsmäßig alles glatt läuft,
finde ich ausgeweites Nachtflugverbot an sich nicht gut, es ist allerdings für die Leute
scheiße, die da wohnen, allerdings wohne ich nicht da, deswegen bin ich da eher mal
neutral, würde ich sagen, also, ähm, wenn ich da wohnen würde, würde ich sagen, äh,
scheiße, will ich nicht, aber so, aber neutral, äh, Mietpreisbremse in Hessen soll wieder
abgeschafft werden, wir haben eine Mietpreisbremse, äh, haben wir das, ok, keine Ahnung, ähm,
verpflichten der Ganztagsunterricht, verpflichten der Ganztagunterricht soll ein mehr weiterführenden
Schulen erst ein, nein, das finde ich blöd, weil ich der Meinung bin, ähm, Kinder sollen
Kinder sein, ja, du kannst Kinder nicht den ganzen Tag in die Schule abschieben und ähm,
sie nicht Kinder sein lassen, die müssen rausgehen, die müssen Scheiße machen, die
müssen auch mal was weiß ich, bisschen Zeug kaputt machen, die müssen sich zusammen
von Fernsehen hocken, Xbox spielen, Playstation spielen, MMOs spielen, aber Ganztagsunterricht
finde ich bescheuert, ja, du solltest Kinder und Jugendliche, Kinder und Jugendliche sein
lassen und sie nicht den ganzen Tag in die Schule abschieben, ich meine das natürlich
für die Eltern ganz nice, weil sie dann ihre Kinder quasi betreut sind, ja, aber verpflichten
der Ganztagsunterricht, äh, ich weiß nicht, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass Schüler wollen
das auch nicht, ja, und ich bin der Meinung, man sollte Kinder und Jugendliche, Kinder
und Jugendliche sein lassen, also der, blödsinn, Windkraftanlage im Waldgebiet, äh, in Hessen
sollen weiterhin Windkraftanlagen in Waldgebieten gebaut werden können, gut, das bedeutet ja,
dazu muss man Wald abholzen, warum kopierst du immer random Wortstücke, weil das so eine
Gewohnheit von mir ist, Shadow Service, was ist Shadow Service, ähm, in Hessen, das bedeutet,
dass man dafür Wald abholzen muss, Hessen ist allerdings das waldreichste Bundesland,
aber warum sollte man, man muss ja dann wirklich ordentlich den Wald platt machen, oder, und
so geil bin ich jetzt eigentlich nicht drauf, dass Wald in Hessen platt gemacht wird, allerdings
finde ich Windkraft an sich nicht schlecht, ja, schwierig, ähm, Abschiebung nach, oh,
jetzt, jetzt kommen die kontroversen Themen, ich sehe es schon, es geht vielleicht mehr
um die Tier- und Vögelwelt, hm, da habe ich mir so keine Sorgen drüber gemacht, ja,
da ist schon was dran, aber neutral, ich glaube, ich glaube da ist mal was dran, jetzt, jetzt
kommen hier die kontroversen Themen, Hessen soll weiterhin abgelehnte Asylbewerberinnen
und Bewerber aus Afghanistan in ihr Heimatland abschieben, naja, sag mal so, nachdem es abgelehnte
Asylbewerber sind, stellt sich mir eigentlich eher die Frage, also, warum, warum das überhaupt
diskutiert werden muss, also, wenn man abgelehnt ist, dann ist ja quasi das Verfahren durch,
ja, solange das ordentlich gelaufen ist und man zu dem Schluss gekommen ist, Leute sind
abgelehnt, haben eigentlich keine Grundlage mehr, dann ist ja die Frage, warum sollen
sie noch da bleiben, also der Sache würde ich eher zustimmen, ich meine, es ist wichtig,
dass der Ablauf eingehalten wird und dass man nicht einfach irgendwelche Leute kickt, ohne
dass man sich das genau angeguckt hat, aber wenn man zu dem Schluss gekommen ist, gibt
es nicht, ja, dann gibt es ja auch keine Grundlage mehr, dass man da bleibt, also der
Sache würde ich eher zustimmen, Betriebe in Hessen, die nicht ausbilden sollen, eine
Abgabe zahlen, ja, in welcher Größe denn, ich meine, man kann jetzt in zwei Mann-Klitsche
nicht dazu zwingen, Leute auszubilden, das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn und du kannst
auch keinen dafür bestrafen, wenn er nicht ausbildet, das sollte den Betrieb eigentlich
aus eigenem Interesse machen, Leute ausbilden, keine Fahrverbote für Dieselfahrzeuge, das
ist eine sehr schwierige Geschichte, ich bin prinzipiell dafür, dass weniger Leute mit
dem Auto in der Stadt rumfahren, allerdings denke ich nicht, dass ein Dieselfahrverbot
die richtige Sache ist, sondern die Alternativen attraktiver machen, dass die Leute weniger
Bock haben mit dem Auto in die Stadt zu fahren, also wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel sagt, okay,
wir wollen weniger, das ist auch das, was ich oftmals so ein bisschen vermisse, ja,
wenn man sagt, ja, Dieselfahrverbot und sonst nichts, ist das einfach zu wenig, wenn man
sagen würde, ja, Dieselfahrverbot, aber im gleichen Zug haben wir einen Plan für das
Ausbauen und Verbessern von öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln, also mehr Züge, die fahren,
mehr Busse, die fahren, Sachen, die pünktlicher sind, mehr Haltestellen, generell die Infrastruktur
besser ausbauen und das ist unser Plan dafür, dass es weniger Fahrzeuge in den Städten
gibt, dann würde ich sagen, ist das gut, aber einfach so, ohne das Ganze zu sagen,
ein Dieselfahrverbot wird wahrscheinlich keine Probleme lösen, das fackt nur die Leute ab,
die sich ein Diesel gekauft haben, vielleicht auch in dem Glauben, dass das eine geile
Geschichte ist, das ist eben wieder ein ganz eigenes Thema, das müsste man eigentlich
anders lösen und zwar nicht mit Verboten von Dieselfahrzeugen, sondern mit dem attraktiver
machen von öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln, ja, man könnte ja zum Beispiel sagen, wie gesagt,
gibt mehr, ist zuverlässiger, ist vielleicht auch nicht mehr privatisiert, ist vielleicht
sogar umsonst, gibt es ja auch immer mal Diskussionen darüber, ob man nicht vielleicht öffentlich
Nahverkehr umsonst machen sollte und wenn es die Alternativen gibt, dann denke ich, werden
die Leute ganz allein nicht mehr mit dem Auto in die Stadt fahren, aber nachdem es jetzt
keine Informationen dazu gibt, also ich finde es gut, weniger Autos in den Städten zu haben,
aber ohne Alternativen nicht, Projekte gegen Rechtsextremismus, Projekte gegen Rechtsextremismus
sollen weiterhin gefördert werden, ich bin der Meinung, dass egal ob Rechtsextremismus,
Linksextremismus, oben oder unten Extremismus, dass alle Projekte in dieser Richtung gleichermaßen
gefördert werden sollen, bedeutet das jetzt, dass das andere Projekt dann nicht gefördert
werden soll, gefördert werden, nee, oder?
Das heißt ja nur die auch und die auch ist ja okay.
Schuldenabbau, Haushaltsüberschüsse des Landes sollen vorrangig für den Schuldenabbau
verwendet werden.
Das ist eine schwierige Geschichte, weil ich bin immer der Meinung, wenn mehr Geld
da ist, sollte es auch nach Möglichkeiten den Leuten, die es indirekt bezahlen, wieder
zu Gute kommen, also wenn man sagt, man verwendet alles für den Schuldenabbau, dann heißt
es ja, dass man über das, was man jetzt schon macht, hinaus nichts Neues macht, weil man
das ja für den Schuldenabbau verwendet, also mal angenommen, keine Ahnung, die Leute brauchen
mehr Kindergartenplätze, würde es nicht geben, weil das Geld, was man mehr hat, in den Schuldenabbau
fließt und nicht in mehr Kindergartenplätze, kann man sich je darüber streiten, ob das
so sinnvoll ist, was hat man davon, das ist schwierig, keine Ahnung, Schuldenabbau, neutral.
An hessischen Schulen soll die Grundschule bis zur 6. Klasse ausgeweilt werden, warum
denn das, bedeutet das dann auch, dass die ganze Schule insgesamt 2 Jahre länger geht,
dann wäre ich sofort dafür, wenn das nicht der Fall ist, sehe ich den Sinn dahinter
nicht. An hessischen Schulen soll die Grundschule bis zur 6. Klasse, warum überhaupt? Hä,
Moment. Ahja, okay, es wird nicht insgesamt länger, sondern es sind einfach nur, man bleibt
einfach länger auf der Grundschule, tatsächlich, das ist mir, ich tendiere zu nein bis zu neutral.
Was das nicht zu früh über die Zukunft des Kindes geurteilt wäre. Finde ich an sich,
ja, warum nicht, ja. Ich war, wenn du ein bisschen älter bist, da hast du wahrscheinlich
auch schon eher den Durchblick, was du machen willst, beziehungsweise man kann es besser
einschätzen, das ist schwierig, neutral. Wahlrecht für Ausländer, alle dauerhaft in Hessen wohnden
nicht EU-Ausländerinnen und Ausländer sollen an den Kommunalwahlen teilnehmen dürfen, warum?
Ist man jetzt Nazi, wenn man sich fragt, wie man auf die Idee kommt, dass quasi jemand,
der nicht deutscher Staatsbürger ist, in Deutschland wählen kann? Also warum? Also wie kommt man
überhaupt auf die Idee, dass das so sein sollte? Ich meine, wenn ich, keine Ahnung, 15 Jahre
in Schweden wohne, darf ich da auch nicht wählen. Also ich denke, wählen sollten eigentlich
nur die Leute dürfen, die Staatsbürger dieses Landes sind. Verstehe jetzt gar nicht, wie
man auf die Idee kommt, das zu ändern. Straßenbaubeiträge, die Kommunen sollen keine Beiträge der Kunststückseigentümer
und Eigentümer, ja das ist auf keinen Fall, das ist so bescheuert. Wir haben hier nicht
weit einen Opa, der, da haben sie die Straße saniert, der müsste jetzt theoretisch sein
Haus verkaufen, dass er die Sanierung der Straße vor seinem Haus bezahlen kann, wovor er nichts
mehr hat, weil er kein Geld hat, die Sanierung zu bezahlen, womit er dann mit seinem Haus
bezahlen müsste, das ist total für den Arsch. Und ich habe auch den Eindruck, dass, zumindest
bei uns hier im Ort, dass manche Straßen absichtlich vergammelt lassen werden, dass man dann später
die Anwohner den Kram bezahlen müssen. Aber du wirst benachteiligt, wenn du lange in einem
Land wohnst und trotzdem nicht wählen darfst. Ja gut, da habe ich Pech, ich bin halt kein
Staatsbürger von Schweden in dem Fall, kann ich ja werden, dann darf ich auch wählen.
Also das will ich nicht, ich will nicht die Straßensanierung bezahlen müssen, weil sie
12 Jahre die Straße nicht gefixt haben. Traditionelles Familienbild. An hessischen Schulen soll ausschließlich
das traditionelle Familienbild Vater, Mutter, Kinder vermitteln. Warum? Die müssen eigentlich
gar kein Familienbild in dem Sinn vermitteln, die sollen einfach sagen, was Sache ist. Keine
Privatisierung von Krankenhäusern. In Hessen sollen keine weiteren Krankenhäuser privatisiert
werden. Jop. Auf jeden Fall, das hat es nicht wirklich besser gemacht. Generell bin ich
der Ansicht, dass Infrastruktur allgemein nicht wirklich privatisiert sein sollte und
auch nicht auf Gewinn ausgelegt sein sollte, sondern auf die möglichst gute Versorgung
von den Leuten, die halt in dieser Region wohnen. Sei es jetzt Abwasser oder Nahverkehr
oder Straßen oder sowas in der Richtung, Telefon, Internet, Kabel, was auch immer, das sollte
nicht dazu da sein, dass man da mit dicke Kohle scheffelt oder dass man es übermäßig
kaputt spart oder sich schön rechnet, sondern es sollte einfach gut funktionieren für die
Leute, das sollte letztendlich für die Leute, die in der Region sind, da sein. Dementsprechend
auch Krankenhäuser. Videoüberwachung. Bei der Videoüberwachung öffentlicher Plätze
in Hessen soll die Gesichtserkennung eingesetzt werden. Nachdem ich da keinem zutraue, nachdem
ich keinem zutraue, das ganze Videomaterial und Zeug ordentlich auszuwerten und ordentlich
zu speichern, ordentlich zu sichern und damit keine Scheiße zu machen, stimme ich nicht
zu. Heimatkunde. Was? Das Land soll sich dafür einsetzen, dass Heimatkunde an weiterführenden
Schulen in Hessen in den Lehrplan aufgenommen wird. Warum brauchen wir denn ein eigenes
Fach dafür? Also ich meine, es ist wichtig, dass man in Geschichte was über das Lernen
lernt, in dem man lebt und auch was in der Vergangenheit passiert ist, auch durch alle
möglichen Epochen durch, aber warum brauchen wir da ein eigenes Fach für, weil wir haben
noch Geschichte im Endeffekt. Weiß ich nicht, brauchen wir nicht. Oder, eins können wir
auch sagen, brauchen wir nicht. Das ist mir wurscht, ich sehe den Sinn davon nicht. Ökologische
Landwirtschaft. Ökologische Landwirtschaft soll bei der Förderung aus Landesmittelvorgang
vor konventioneller Landwirtschaft haben. Ich esse gerne Öko-Eier. Wer kann ich dazu nicht
sagen? Erinnerungskultur. Die Verbrechen der National-, oh jetzt kommen aber, jetzt kommen
aber die Hammer-Themen, ey. Die Verbrechen der nationalsozialistischen Diktatur sollen
weiterhin zentraler Bestandteil der hessischen Erinnerungskultur bleiben. Ja, aber wie sage
ich das jetzt am besten? Also es ist auf jeden Fall wichtig, dass man sich immer wieder in
Erinnerung ruft, was passiert ist, vor allem auch im Hinblick auf aktuelle Entwicklung,
was man auch eben erkennen kann. Gewisse Parallelen. Und dass alle wissen, was damals passiert
ist. Ob man jetzt allerdings wirklich quasi jede Woche irgendwelche Kranzniederlegungen
und Denkmäler und Gedöns braucht, ich weiß nicht. Aber prinzipiell würde ich der Sache
schon zustimmen. So, Landesmindestlohn. Warte, habe ich mich verklickt? Oh, äh, ups.
Auch weiterhin zentraler Bestandteil bleiben, aber ich glaube, das passt doch. Landesmindestlohn.
Also, um darauf zurückzukommen, ich finde es ist einfach wichtig, dass man es auch für
zukünftige Generationen in Erinnerung behält und auch darüber Bescheid weiß. Und vor allem
halt, dass man erkennt, auch in der heutigen Zeit, dass es an manchen Stellen ja auch schon
gewisse Parallelen gibt. Ich finde es zum Beispiel auch bedenklich, dass man zum Beispiel
sagt, wenn man sich mal anguckt, dass zum Beispiel die AfD, dass da sehr wenig mit diskutiert
wird, ja, dass man, dass man quasi sagt, ok, alles kagnazis und dementsprechend man die
Chance verschenkt, die Leute, die Leute davon zu überzeugen, dass man Recht hat. Also sprich,
man kann es ja auf zwei Arten machen. Ja, man kann jetzt quasi sagen, AfD scheiße, mit
denen reden wir nicht. Oder aber, und das ist das, wovon ich denke, dass die Leute mehr
überzeugt, man könnte sagen, ähm, wir diskutieren mit der AfD, allerdings nehmen wir das als
Chance den Leuten zu erzählen, was wir, also was die anderen, ja, was wir davon denken
und können so die Leute davon überzeugen, dass das andere Blödsinn ist. Wenn man nämlich
gar nicht mit den Leuten redet, dann kann man sich auch nicht überzeugen. Und deswegen
finde ich, es ist wichtig, dass man generell über solche Sachen redet und dementsprechend
sich auch die Geschichte anguckt und schaut, wie da manche Sachen gelaufen sind und Sachen
irgendwie zu verschweigen oder, ähm, ja, erstmal überhaupt nicht drüber zu reden
ist generell ein Problem, weil das eher dazu führt, dass die Leute sich nicht verstanden
fühlen und wenn sich Leute nicht verstanden fühlen, machen sie irgendeinen Blödsinn.
Deswegen finde ich es auch nicht sinnvoll, wenn man sagt, beispielsweise, man lädt von
den Rechten oder von der AfD oder von irgendeinem, lädt man keinen ein zu irgendeinem Talkshow.
Das ist eigentlich, finde ich, genau der falsche Ansatz. Du musst die eigentlich gerade einladen
und dann die Leute davon überzeugen, dass das, was du sagst, quasi sinniger ist als
das, was die sagen. So kannst du die Leute überzeugen, anders geht das ja nicht. Ja,
wenn du einfach sagst, oh, kack, Spaß, mit dir rede ich nicht, überzeugt halt keinen.
Es geht nicht darum, die Leute von der AfD oder von irgendwelchen Rechten oder Link-Extremen
zu überzeugen, es geht darum, die Leute, die Talkshow hören, davon zu überzeugen, ähm,
von dem, was man sagt. Nicht, wenn irgendwelche extreme Leute, kannst du nicht überzeugen,
deswegen sind sie ja extrem. Aber du kannst quasi, wenn du mit extremen Leuten redest
im Fernsehen und wenn du sie einlädst zu irgendwas, kannst du die Zuschauer davon überzeugen.
Du hast immer noch Science und Technology. Kannst du die Zuhörer davon überzeugen von
dem, was du sagst. Wenn du schon von Anfang an sagst, mit den kack Spaßen rede ich nicht,
hast du die Chance vertan. Und dann werden viele Leute sagen, ja, okay, scheint dir
nichts dagegen einzufallen, dann hast recht. Ich weiß halt nicht, ob es zentraler Bestandteil
sein sollte, ähm, worum es hier letztendlich geht, aber, ähm, im Prinzip ist das eigentlich
auch so eine Sache, die uns halt schon auch für immer anhaften wird. Deswegen ist es
auch wichtig, dass man sich damit auseinandersetzt. So, nächstes. Mit der AfD zu diskutieren
ist halt unmöglich, wenn die Zuhörer die dreiste Methodik hinter deren Argumente verstehen.
Ähm, generell finde ich, das bescheuertste, was man machen kann, ist eben nicht zu diskutieren,
weil das dazu führt, dass die Leute quasi noch überzeugt davon irgendwas sind. Also,
mit sowas nähert ja letztendlich auch die ganzen Verschwörungstheorien irgendwie. Ja,
so nach dem Motto, ah, die sind so blöd, da muss man gar nicht drüber reden und ah,
sind die alle unfähig. Klar, du wirst nicht alle überzeugen können, aber wenn du mit,
wenn du erst gar nicht drüber redest, bestärkt das ganz viele Leute noch da drin, ähm, dir
nicht zu glauben und den anderen. Deswegen sollte man wirklich auch die Leute einladen,
ja, und mit denen diskutieren und oftmals ist es ja so, dass, ähm, sich dann Leute schon
selbst komplett ins Abseil schießen, wenn sie irgend ne Blödsinn erzählen. Aber einfach,
wenn man nicht drüber redet, ist es noch viel bescheuerter. Generell, das ist in Deutschland
allgemein so ein Problem, was ich finde, dass wir viele Sachen, dass wir über viele Sachen
nicht reden, ja, ähm, sobald es droht, dass irgendwas politisch inkorrekt wird, wird da
nicht drüber geredet. Egal ob das notwendig ist oder nicht, sei es jetzt irgendwelche
Feminismusthemen, äh, Sachen aus, ja, aus der Lazizeit oder, äh, Frauen und Männer
oder was, was du noch so alles für kontroverse Themen aktuell hast, ja, Frauen in Führungsetagen,
ähm, und sonst was, ähm, sobald das droht, dass irgendwie mal einer, der eine nicht
ganz, äh, konforme Meinung hat, wird da lieber gar nicht drüber geredet. Dabei sollte man
doch eigentlich gerade darüber reden, weil letztendlich reden tut ja keinem weh, ähm,
die Sachen, die vielleicht aus nicht Reden resultieren, schon eher. Weil reden hat, über
irgendwas hat ja noch keinem geschadet. Und ich denke, es ist einfach so, umso weniger
du Sachen thematisierst, umso schneller hast du extreme Leute. Weil, wenn man sich überlegt,
wie jemand extrem wird, ist das einmal natürlich durch die Beschallung von anderen extremen
Leuten. Aber das muss ja auf gewissen Nährboten fallen. Also sprich, das müssen ja Leute sein,
die sich überzeugen lassen. Und Leute, die sich von der restlichen Welt, sagen wir mal,
nicht richtig verstanden fühlen, oder nicht richtig verdrehten fühlen, die sind natürlich
nochmal deutlich empfänglicher für irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Und deswegen denke
ich, es ist gerade wichtig, dass wir über alle möglichen Scheiß reden, auch wenn er
unangenehm ist. Ich mein, irgendwann muss man es ja mal machen. Aber deswegen finde
ich es auch bescheuert, dass es in den letzten, ähm, Jahren, wo es um, äh, um, äh, quasi
die Zuwanderung ging, dass da immer nicht richtig drüber geredet wurde. Sobald einer
mal was gesagt hat, äh, was, was nicht ganz so massenkompatibel war, wurde nicht über
den Inhalt diskutiert, sondern die übliche Nazi-Geschichte ausgepackt, Alter, du Kackspaß,
sowas kannst du doch nicht sagen, und als Maul. Und das sieht man, das hat die Leute
nicht überzeugt. Das hat die Leute absolut nicht überzeugt. Was meint, was meint ihr,
warum so viele Leute jetzt, äh, Sachen in der rechten, aus der rechten Ecke wählen,
oder damit, ähm, liebäugeln, einfach weil sie sich nicht ver-, weil sie ihre Anliegen
und Interessen nicht richtig vertreten fühlen und sich nicht richtig verstanden fühlen
und nicht denken, dass, ähm, was für sie gemacht wird. So, und deswegen denke ich,
es ist wichtig, dass man sich gerade über solche Sachen Gedanken macht. So, äh. Ja,
Talkshow gab es zu dem Thema viele, aber das ging oftmals immer nur in die gleiche
Richtung. Du musst, bei sowas musst du Leute einladen, die auch mal was kontroverses loslassen
dürfen, wo man dann halt auch drüber reden kann. Und, ähm, nur so kannst du, denke
ich, die Leute davon überzeugen, dass das, was du sagst, halt letztendlich überzeugender
ist. Wenn du in der Talkshow quasi zehn Leute sitzen hast, die mehr oder weniger ins gleiche
Horn blasen, mit Variationen drin, ja, dann überzeugt das die Leute nicht. So, jetzt
gehen wir mal weiter. Warum habe ich hier mal zu Beginn gesehen? Okay, ähm, Landesmindestlohn.
Unternehmen, die Aufträge vom Land erhalten sollen einen höheren Mindestlohn, Landesmindestlohn
zahlen müssen. Warum? Warum sollte der Mindestlohn für Aufträge vom Land höher sein? Ich,
also wenn mich einer fragt, die sollen generell den Leuten per Mindestlohn bezahlen, aber
warum sollte das höher sein, wenn der Auftrag vom Land ist? Außer, dass es dann letztendlich
mehr kostet. Und dreimal dürfen wir raten, wer das dann wieder bezahlen darf am Ende.
Also, ich bin generell dafür, dass die Leute mehr Geld verdienen, ja. Aber jetzt nur in
diesem einen Fall? Weiß nicht. Förderschulen, Förderschulen für Kinder mit Behinderungen
sollen in Hessen erhalten, bleiben wir klar. Wir sollten auf die Idee kommen, die abzuschaffen.
Du solltest denen, du solltest, ähm, das, äh, den Leuten schon ermöglichen, wenn sie
wollen und können, auch in eine normale Schule zu gehen, klar. Aber wenn es, äh, wenn die
Betreuung und die Förderung in einer Förderschule besser ist, oder wie haben sie es genannt,
wird in einer Förderschule besser ist? Warum nicht? Warum sollte man das abschaffen? Vielleicht
haben sie ja zu wenig Lehrer für Förderschulen, das kann natürlich sein. Dass man sich denkt,
man hat zu wenig Lehrer für Förderschulen, jetzt steckt man sich in die normalen Schulen
und dann wird alles besser, was ja irgendwie auch keinen Sinn ergibt. Kommunale Grundversorgung,
die kommunale Grundversorgung, Gas, Wasser, Strom, soll ausschließlich in öffentlicher
Anzahl, ja. Da bin ich dafür. Ich bin angekommen, wie es mit der Bahnberg abgegangen ist. Manche
argumentieren nur totale Inklusion des Menschen mit, wenn sie wollen, ich habe ja keine Schmerzen
damit, wenn jetzt jemand sagt, er möchte in die normale Schule gehen, oder besser gesagt,
wenn das seine Eltern sagen, ist doch vollkommen okay. Wer sollte das den Leuten schon ermöglichen?
Aber andersrum auch. Und wenn die Eltern sagen, ich denke, mein Kind ist besser in der Förderschule
aufgehoben, dann sollte man das auch machen können. Bau von Moscheen, in Hessen sollen
keine weiteren Moscheen gebaut werden. Ja gut, in Deutschland darf jeder glauben, was
man will, in Hessen auch. Dementsprechend muss es da halt auch Sachen geben, wo man beten
kann, ja. Und das jetzt einer, es geht ja nicht nur um eine Moschee, es kann ja keine,
alle möglichen Gotteshäuser, was es da so gibt, sein. Dass man da erstmal 300 Kilometer
für fahren muss, kann ja auch nicht sein. Also, pff, die können meinetwegen Moscheen
bauen, die können auch Kirchen bauen und sonst was. Ich meine, wir brauchen jetzt nicht
an jeder Ecke eine Moschee, genauso wie wir an jeder Ecke eine Kirche brauchen, oder,
was gibt es denn da noch so? Keine Ahnung, wir haben in Frankfurt jetzt eine Scientology
Kirche. Ich bin jetzt wurscht. Ähm, Eltern unabhängiges BAföG. Das Land Hessen soll
sich dafür einsetzen, dass BAföG generell unabhängig vom Einkommen der Eltern gezahlt
wird. Also sprich, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe,
heißt das quasi unabhängig davon, wie viel die Eltern haben. Nö, warum? Wenn die Eltern
massig Kohle haben, können sie ihre Kinder doch unterstützen, das ist doch vollkommen
in Ordnung. Und sollten sie auch, weil sie sind die Eltern. Machen ihr Eltern vor Leuten,
die nicht so viel Geld haben auch. So, wenn es die Eltern dicke haben, können sie auch
ihre Kinder unterstützen. Polizei-Einsätze bei Großveranstaltungen. Bei kommerziellen
Großveranstaltungen sollen sich die Veranstalter an den Kosten für den Polizeieinsatz beteiligen.
Nee, ich würde sagen, Polizeieinsätze sind erstmal eine Landesgeschichte. Ob das jetzt
kommerzielle Großveranstaltungen sind, oder irgendwelche Demos sind, oder irgendwelche
Charity-Konzerte sind, oder was auch immer. Na gut, wenn es, sag mal so, wenn es eine
kommerzielle Großveranstaltung ist, sagen wir mal so was wie Rock am Ring. Für Krankenwagen
und so musst du ja auch was bezahlen als Veranstalter. Du darfst ja so eine Veranstaltung gar nicht
machen ohne genug Krankenwagen und Sanitäter und Gedöns. Also warum sollte man sich nicht
auch an Polizeikosten für seine kommerzielle Großveranstaltung beteiligen müssen? Keine
Ahnung. Also, ich würde sagen, es klingt jetzt erstmal nicht übel. Ich weiß jetzt
nicht, was daraus folgt. Da müsste ich mal ein bisschen mehr Gedanken drüber machen.
Wählen ab 16. Jugendliche sollen bei der Landtagswahl ab 16 Jahren wählen dürfen.
Aber da bin ich wahrscheinlich unbeliebt, wenn ich sage nein. Warum, könnte ich doch
dazu sagen. Das liegt gar nicht mal so sehr daran, dass ich denke, Leute mit 16 haben
keine Ahnung. Ich denke, rein vom Ansatz her könnten Leute mit 16 auch ohne Probleme wählen
gehen. Allerdings glaube ich, dass so ein bisschen die, so ein bisschen der Rundumblick
fehlt oder beziehungsweise ein bisschen auch die Erfahrung. Weil wenn du 16 bist, gehst
du eigentlich in die Schule, so gerade noch. Dementsprechend kennst du eigentlich nicht
viel anderes außer die Schule. Das heißt, zu vielen Themen kannst du da eh relativ
wenig was sagen und hast eigentlich mehr oder weniger eins zu eins die Weltanschauung und
Meinung, die man eben in der Schule vermittelt bekommt. Also das heißt, es könnte im Prinzip
dazu führen, dass da halt die vielleicht was wählen, was sie gar nicht wollen, keine
Ahnung, weil sie es nicht besser wissen. Ich weiß es nicht. Also ich glaube, mit 16 hat
man einfach nicht so den Überblick. Ich will nicht sagen, dass man den mit 34 irgendwann
hat. Zentrale Einrichtung für Asylbewerber. Jetzt kommen wieder diese Themen. Alle Asylbewerberinnen
und Bewerber sollen bis zur Entscheidung über ihren Antrag in zentralen Einrichtungen untergebracht
werden. Seht ihr das nicht jetzt schon? Ich meine, es wird ja nicht mal einer da, einer
da, einer da, einer da sein. Und irgendwie ein bisschen gesammelt organisiert muss man
die Leute ja unterbringen. Oder meinen die damit irgendwie 5000 Leute in ein Haus stecken
oder so. Also ich denke mal, so auf den ersten Blick, was hätten zentrale Einrichtungen
für Vorteile? Es kann sich wahrscheinlich nicht eine an 20 Stellen registrieren und
man findet die Leute wieder. Das wünsche ich mir jetzt mal so zusammenreimen auf den
ersten Blick. Es müssten sich manche Omas nicht aufregen, dass bei ihnen gegenüber
ein Wohnheim ist mit 50 Afghanen. Aber ansonsten wüsste ich ja nicht, was das für ein Vorteil
hat. Ich würde sagen, man sollte die Leute so unterbringen, wie das logistisch und organisatorisch
am besten ist. Und ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das besser funktioniert, weil man alle
Leute in quasi zentral hat oder besser verteilt. Weil ich meine, man hat ja auch die Unterbringung
und das ganze Zeug, man hat es ja nicht unbedingt zentral alles. Vielleicht ist es besser,
wenn man das verteilt macht. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Dazu kommt auch noch, wenn man, fällt
mir gerade so ein, also wenn man jetzt mal angenommen wirklich alle Leute quasi in einer
Unterkunft unterbringt, ja das haben wir nicht alle, sagen wir mal 5000 oder so, dann kann
es natürlich auch sein, dass da viele Leute auf engem Raum wohnen, die halt von ihrer
Herkunft her und so, nennen wir es mal Feinde sind, gibt ja, wenn jetzt Leute aus dem gleichen
Land fliehen, müssen die nicht unbedingt von der gleichen Fraktion kommen, die können
sich dann auch hier schon gegenseitig nicht mehr ab. Und es führt dazu, und das sieht
man ja auch in vielen Vorstädten in anderen Ländern, wo quasi viele, sagen wir mal Mexikaner
sind oder viele, keine Ahnung, aus einem Teil der Welt viele Leute in einen anderen Teil
der Welt gehen, dass sich dann quasi, so was wie Ghettos oder sowas bildet, so Seilschaften
zwischen den Leuten, sprich, dass man wenig mitkriegt von der Sache drum herum, weil man
das nicht muss, deswegen wäre dezentral vielleicht besser, vielleicht ist man dann nicht mehr
so gefangen in der ganzen Sache, wisst ihr, wie ich meine. Also wenn man jetzt quasi
mit 5000 Leuten, die quasi alle die gleiche Sprache oder aus der ähnlichen Ecke kommen
und ähnliche Ansichten haben und die unter sich bleiben, riesen, riesen Haufen, da wird
sich wahrscheinlich nicht so viel von hier durchsetzen. Also, vielleicht sieht zentral
auch nicht schlecht. Ich hab mich ehrlich gesagt mit dem Thema viel zu wenig beschäftigt,
da ich da jetzt was Qualifiziertes zu sagen könnte. Ja, richtig deep am evaluieren. Genau,
das ist auch noch was, Knäbe, richtig. Klar, wenn du viele Leute auf engem Raum hast, da
schaukelt sich auch viel hoch und wenn du da ein paar dabei hast, die, sagen wir mal,
rhetorisch gewandt sind, ähm, gewisse Meinungen unter die Leute zu bringen, hast du auch mal
ganz schnell welche am randalieren. Man sagt, dass dezentral zu weniger Ghetto-Bildung und
weniger Kriminalität führt. Das hätte ich mir jetzt auch so zusammengereimt, ja. Genauso
hätt ich mir das jetzt auch gedacht. Aber so wirklich, ich kann es nicht so wirklich
bewerten, da muss ich mir jetzt wirklich, ich mach mal neutral, da muss ich mir jetzt
wirklich mehr Gedanken zu machen. Also ich kann jetzt weder ja sein, also ich tendiere
eher zu stimmen nicht zu, da machen wir einfach mal stimme nicht zu. Und wir machen, komm,
wir machen neutral. Also ich tendiere zwar eher zu stimmen nicht zu, aber da muss ich
mir noch mal eine Weile Gedanken drüber machen. Kostenloser öffentlicher privater
Nahverkehr. Das Land Hessen soll für seine Bürgerinnen und Bürger ein landesweites kostenloses
Ticket für den öffentlichen Personennahverkehr finanzieren. Jopp, sollen sie. Landesamt
für Verfassungsschutz soll aufgelöst werden. Haben die was angestellt? Wisst ihr das, haben
die was gemacht? Haben die irgendwas angestellt, warum die jetzt, warum die aufgelöst werden
sollen? Kein Schimmer. Religionsunterricht. Der konfessionelle Religionsunterricht soll
abgeschafft werden. Kein Mensch braucht Religionsunterricht. Man sollte sowas wie Ethik machen, wo dann
es auch Pflicht ist, dass alle daran teilnehmen. Und darin, man kann es ja weiterhin Religionsunterricht
sogar nennen. Allerdings sollte es da um, quasi um die gesamte Welt gehen. Religionsunterricht
sollte nicht um, wie sagt man so schön, klerikale, nee, keine Ahnung, also nicht um geistliche
Inhalte gehen, sondern Religionsunterricht in Form von, ja, was gibt es eigentlich alles
für Religionen? Was machen die so? Wo gibt es die so? Was haben die in der Vergangenheit
für komische Dinge gemacht? Wo man dann sehen wird, viele nehmen sich da eigentlich gar
nicht sonderlich viel. Im Auftrag des Herrn wurden schon unglaublich viele Leute gekillt,
egal wie er jetzt genau heißt. Oder wer gerade wem den Kopf einschlägt. Über Jahrhunderte
lang war es wunderbar gängig, dass man, hat's gereicht, dass man im Auftrag des Herrn
irgendwas macht. Das ist ja heute in vielen Teilen der Welt auch so. Das hat ja wunderbar
funktioniert. Also, sich damit zu beschäftigen ist nicht verkehrt. Deswegen, geistliche Inhalte
im Religionsunterricht braucht man nicht. Religionsunterricht über Religionen, das
sollte man machen. Leistungskürzung Hartz IV. Hartz IV Empfängerinnen und Empfänger
sollen in Hessen weiterhin die Leistung gekürzt werden, wenn sie Jobangebote ablehnen. Da
bin ich persönlich hin und her gerissen, weil auf der einen Seite könnte man natürlich
sagen, es supportet Leute, die absichtlich nichts machen. Auf der anderen Seite muss
man ja mal sagen, wenn jemand jetzt keine Ahnung was, irgendwas gelernt hat, irgendwas,
Schreiner, es ist egal was, ja, und soll dann zum Spargelstechen abkommandiert werden.
Weil das ist ja keine Sklavenarbeit. Da bin ich prinzipiell schon dafür, dass der sagen
kann, leck mich am Arsch. Schwierig, neutral. Gefahrenabwehr Gefährderinnen und Gefährder
sollen länger als 6 Tage vorsorglich in Gewahrsam genommen werden. Nachdem es wahrscheinlich
wieder unglaublich schwierig ist zu definieren, wer genau eine Gefährderin und Gefährder
ist, sehe ich darin eher die Gefahr, dass man das missbraucht für Dinge, wofür es
nicht gedacht ist. Ähnlich wie mit der Kamera, mit der Gesichtserkennung vorher, wo ich es
auch keinem richtig zugetraut habe, das ordentlich durchzuführen, würde ich auch sagen, ich
meine 6 Tage sind 6 Tage. Und wenn man was Handfestes hat, geht das auch mehr als 6 Tage.
Aber einfach mal auf gut Glück. Näh. Besoldung von Lehrern. In Hessen sollen Lehrerinnen
und Lehrer aller Schulformen das gleiche Einstiegsgehalt erhalten. Ja, da kommt es
jetzt drauf an. Wenn alle, also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass die meinen damit, dass
das quasi, sagen wir jetzt mal, ein Grundschullehrer weniger verdient als ein Gymnasiumlehrer oder
so, falls das so ist. Ich weiß es gar nicht, ehrlich gesagt, ob das wirklich so ist. Aber
ich könnte es mir vorstellen, ich finde es wichtig, dass die Leute nach ihrem Können bezahlt werden,
wobei es schwierig ist zu sagen, wie man Können definiert. Vielleicht ist die Ausbildung
rein vom fachlichen Inhalt her schwieriger für einen Gymnasiumlehrer, dafür brauchst
du als Grundschullehrer bestimmt andere Kompetenzen. Deswegen würde ich sagen, man kann den Leuten
schon das gleiche Geld geben, allerdings allen das höhere. Also sprich nicht, dass jetzt
alle das niedrige kriegen, sondern alle mehr. Weil ordentliche Lehrer brauchen wir auf jeden
Fall. Aber das kann man hier ja nicht ankreuzen. Neutral. Flughafen Kassel-Kallen, das Land
Hessen soll seinen Anteil am Flughafen Kassel-Kallen verkaufen. Ich wusste nicht mal, dass wir
dafür überhaupt Anteile haben, keine Ahnung. Sprachkurse für Flüchtlinge, in Hessen sollen
weiterhin kostenlose Sprachkurse für Flüchtlinge angeboten werden. Warum nicht? So ein Sprachkurs
wird nicht die Welt kosten und wird auch garantiert nicht schaden. Es ist jetzt zwar
zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht geklärt, ob die Leute dann da bleiben dürfen oder nicht,
aber Schaden tut es mit Sicherheit nicht. So ein Sprachkurs, wo dann pro Sprachkurs
30 Leute locken, das wird jetzt nicht die Welt kosten. Also im einen Bereich der Tatsache,
dass es mit Sicherheit nicht schaden wird, wenn die Leute Deutsch können oder zumindest
ein bisschen besser Deutsch können, ist das bestimmt nicht verkehrt. Projekte gegen
Linksextremismus sollen weiterhin gefördert werden. Jawohl, die Projekte gegen Rechtsextremismus
haben am Anfang ja auch gesagt, dass sie weiter gefördert werden sollen. Private Wohnungen
sollen als Ferienwohnungen vermietet werden dürfen. Ja, warum nicht? Das ist meine Wohnung.
Kinderbetreuung. Eltern sollen sich weiterhin an den Kosten für die Betreuung ihrer Kinder
unter drei Jahren beteiligen. Da muss ich mal was Soziales sagen. Ich bin der Meinung,
Kindergartenplätze sollten kostenlos sein. Generell sollten solche Sachen in guter Qualität
jedem zur Verfügung stehen. Auch ordentliche Behandlung. Einem Arzt, wo es nicht sein kann,
dass man ein halbes Jahr warten soll. Mittlerweile bin ich so weit, dass ich viele Sachen schon
selbst bezahle, weil ich da keinen Bock mehr drauf habe. Und das wurde über die letzten
Jahre in ganz vielen Bereichen einfach nur noch immer beschissener. Deswegen bin ich
der Ansicht, Kindergartenplätze und sonst was dürfen ruhig kostenlos sein. Das Problem
ist, dass die Kindergärten pleite gehen. Da muss man denen halt ordentlich Geld bezahlen.
Das eine schließt das andere ja nicht aus. Nur weil das für die Leute kostenlos ist,
heißt das ja nicht, dass die Kindergärten kein Geld kriegen sollen. Ah, neutral. Grundeinkommen.
In Hessen sollen Modellversuche zur Einführung eines bedingungslosen Grundeinkommens durchgeführt
werden. Ja, sollen. Es geht hier ja wohlgemerkt um Modellversuche. Und das bin ich der Meinung,
dass wird eines der großen Herausforderungen werden der Nächsten, keine Ahnung, 50, 70,
100 Jahre sowas hier hinzubekommen. Und ob es funktioniert, keine Ahnung. Aber Versuche
sollen es auf jeden Fall machen. Okay, okay, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, was da rausgekommen
ist. Okay, wählen wir mal so die üblichen Verdächtigen aus. Natürlich die AfD müssen
wir noch auswählen, dass wir mal gucken, wie viel Nazi in uns jetzt steckt. Ja, nicht,
dass das jetzt auf die Goldwaage gelegt wird. Das geht jetzt mir eher um so das, was immer
halt der ganze Sache nachgesagt wird. So, natürlich noch die grauen Panther. Ich meine,
ich bin immerhin 34. Und dann vergleichen wir das Ganze noch mit der NPD und die Partei.
Die machen wir auch noch. Bitte nehmen Sie eine Partei hin. Okay, dann nehmen wir die
grauen Panther raus. Okay, weiter. Die Partei, 54%, AfD 63%. Okay. Also, das heißt, ich
sollte morgen die Partei wählen, gefolgt von der AfD. Aha. NPD 48%, die Linke 50%,
die Gründe 52%. Also, gar nicht so viel Unterschied zwischen links und nicht ganz so links. Ja,
alles Nazis, ja. Aber, ich meine, ich habe die Punkte begründet und was man daran sieht,
ist, wie ich gesagt habe, mir bringen diese ganzen Phanomats-Sachen meistens nicht so
viel. Weil ich oftmals so Dinger so eng beisammen habe, die so komplett entgegengesetzt sind.
Ja. Oh, ne, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht mehr an. Okay, Leute. Alter, wie viele Leute
jetzt zugucken? Okay, ihr wisst, was das heißt. Autosong. Ich hoffe, euch hat der Stream gefallen.
Macht's gut. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss.